Monday it's March 6 here at the H3
podcast welcome everybody
I know you missed us we missed you too
today it's uh
March 6th boy I'll tell you what
the time is is moving on by
I feel like we're going to be like we're
just gonna be dead pretty soon here
oh
just do you fear death Eddie no no fear
of death I really feel like we're you
know it's no no problem that's good
that's that's wise thank you Eddie I
appreciate that no problem
Eddie says to death no problem
today's episode is sponsored by gamer
sups and honey
thank you so much we love them so much
thank you to our beautiful sponsors
Eddie's back with us thanks for coming
out again
[Music]
we actually have a special project for
Eddie today
at Mr Beast as you know is under attack
oh yeah his display chocolate displays
at Walmart people have been messing up
and Jimmy aka Mr Beast has put out a
call on Twitter for people to please if
they're in Walmart just clean up his
display
and since he's since he's done that
people have said no Fu Jimmy I'm going
there messing up your display
and as you know the as the war drums
sound
um and you being the expert of Walmart
we were going to send you out there with
Cam to guard to protect the chocolate
displays to make sure that Nobody messes
with it they stay clean
that sounds like a plan man I like that
plan and I can do that I can it's
possible it's possible we can do good
I like your can-do attitude
man we're manning the barricades
um so that's exciting
very much looking forward to that today
uh actually I want to honor you a little
bit Eddie you've got a great Tick Tock
here you had a banger hey Eddie what
happens when Eddie meets Eddie
World of Sports are you doing outside
without a shirt on
my name is Eddie also I will take off my
shirt if you would take yours on my name
is Eddie just like your name is Eddie
and you said you take your shirt off if
I took my shirt off so on bed and you
will do that I'm Eddie so take your
shirt off too so what am I gonna do
I got my shirt off because I'm Eddie
like you so we both have our shirts off
yeah we both have our shirts off because
we're both enemies
wow dude this is a masterpiece
so is this some random guy yeah I was
walking my dog and I had no idea he was
going to be so energetic and willing to
do it and give me all the energy and
attention good Eddies are good peoples
yeah yeah
also I had to ask you something this a
lot popped up since you've been on the
show lots of people spotting you in
movies shows
here's one I absolutely had to ask you
about I have an old friend Trisha Paytas
I used to do a show with her oh yeah
what dreams are made of music video we
spotted you in the Crowd Oh My Gosh
Ethan that is incredible do you remember
this oh yes I was really into it because
I like that song and I thought she did a
great job she was impeccable she kind of
was better than the original Hilary Duff
wow
and I really got energetic and I started
clap you know being really into it good
job was it a long day did they mistreat
you on set well they do kind of drag on
long time and you've got to sit there
and you know have there is some down
time but we had fun and there was a lot
of uh of uh good good music to listen to
and so we had a good time right did they
have a knife do you remember that
they've added a nice craft service yeah
they had good craft service and a nice
meal so I had a good time I'm actually
impressed she did it pretty official
because this was like an official sag uh
Guild role for you right yeah
whereas like a Darman doesn't do that
that's right okay takes that five
percent
that's her sister oh
she was yeah it's hard to explain long
story that's just incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
um also
somebody found while we're on the topic
of Eddie
some acting credentials wow this is your
resume
this is your resume yes improvisational
we know that improvisational long form
we know that BMX
yeah yeah I probably did some BMX
mountain biking videos or something are
you prepared to ride a BMX bike right
now yeah
really mountain biking okay Arrow Arrow
aerobics that's pretty General
disco dancing yeah really
pop and lock I gotta see that oh that's
uh really not in my forte wait is this
not that somebody must have made this up
here for me okay all right I see
I see what they're trying yeah yeah well
okay make me more sporty or you know
apparently this is your listed skills
why does it lie it says these are act
yeah these acting skills
I don't know if this is from like some
kind of acting bio yeah it could have
been from maybe an acting bio or a
website where they hire actors so they
wanted you to have some athletic skills
just in case got it
so so you we can't do any of this stuff
here probably not I could do the
aerobics or step aerobics or any kind of
uh things like that right that's okay
well let's get on to um
some stories here we got a great show
planned for you guys and then eventually
you guys are going to take off to
Walmart because yeah there is a war
happening so
um we've got uh child influencers are
getting some legal protection uh
we're fixing his mic here thank you baby
yeah just extra time thank you so much
yeah thanks thank you
um we got all kinds of good stuff let's
just start from the top we've got here
you know the the corridor and Jeremy he
he pees in his basement that's what he's
known for oh and um
or he's actually been having like a
total meltdown on Twitter it's actually
pretty interesting although I've heard
some people Dan saying that it was a
it's a goof and that he's trying to like
goof on Libs or something like taking
the bait I don't know seems like he's
trying pretty hard to burn the bridge
quartering has gone completely nuclear
he's an enemy of the show uh oh yeah
the coordinator's gone completely
nuclear and is claiming to reveal the
truth about his far-right colleagues
being closeted homosexuals or sexually
obsessed with trans people
he claims to expose Elijah Schaefer Jack
uh postal biak
how do you say that Apostle Beck I'm I'm
I don't know and Mike cernovich
um you know I don't have a hard time
believing that these are he's talking
about conservatives who are like very
bigoted and homophobic being closeted
themselves that happens right
so
Jordan white says yes the harsh truth is
that many are [__] smokers that's vulgar
did people learn nothing from John
Goldberg AKA Giga chat Indie porn Jack
Murphy
the corner said yep wife cheater fake
religious trans [__] lovers that's just
Jesus why so vulgar bro this is a lot I
don't understand how this would be
satire of uh
it's not yeah it's not it doesn't really
add up basically irrefutable but maybe I
I don't know I'd be a comedic genius and
he's so beyond our comprehension that's
impossible
I like on one hand What's Happening Here
in that the quartering is burning the
bridges with all of his potential allies
and then at the same time like I [__]
hate him and he's just gonna be so
isolated I like that for him yeah all
he's going to have left is his wife and
she's gone for pizza she's gone yeah
well
my wife went out furniture without me he
says I've hung out with these people IRL
hahaha why did he flip on them so hard
like what happened to the quartering
does anyone know why what ticked them
off I I really don't uh it's the minutia
of their slap fights is is lost on me a
lot of the time wait why does this say
paid
what does that mean is that a new
Twitter thing
um
[__]
I don't know they're changing things
every day you know it was like broken
all morning yeah right like no links no
images
Elon Musk is doing a good he's doing a
good job over there I'm sweaty I'm fat
I'm overweight yeah we know
uh cat uh responds to him says can you
prove it excuse me if I don't believe
you just because you say so prove it
instead of just claiming it says he
wrote a whole article about sucking
trans [__] do people not do an ounce of
research I don't
he's in the he's in the weeds that's
what I'm saying it's like it's so it's
so in the weeds I'm deep undercover Mike
cernovich loves trans [__] he says it
don't get me wrong right Mike cernovich
is an apple salute psychopath yeah he's
a weirdo but um
I'm not sure that's the ultimate insult
that somebody loves transcock
maybe if they're going there in their
world that is yeah I guess if they're
transphobic
but he's really
um
he's putting it all out there
laying on the line loads of right-wing
commentators are either closeted gays or
I can't even say that he's using like
slurs now
bro
come on now
you think he was just hitting the sauce
you know he was drunk there's no
question about it the question is what
else was he on like was he on Percocets
as well was he you know was he I can't
imagine this man could actually
um
maintain a marriage
that makes no sense to me that he's
remained married why do you care
I guess I don't really care I just I'm
just it makes me wonder because you seem
so dysfunctional yeah I knew something
was up
that's what I heard yeah that's where
we're all here kind of thinking
oh the Mexican Tana
said uh thank you for the dog she said
lunch is on me today love you all so
much
the Mexican Tana the Mexican Tana shout
out thank you so much Mexican Tana
lunchtime iron cutting chalets
hey guys today's my wife's JoJo's
birthday and she's turning 27. we're
both long time viewers and really Bond
over your videos we don't love to get a
birthday shout out love you thank you
happy birthday Queen
oh so the paid thing is an extension
that can show you who paid for the oh
that's awesome oh that's clever because
I do think people need to be shamed for
that right I don't think it's adequate
that you have to hover over this you
know how do you feel about people paying
for Twitter blue
I think it's wrong because you know it's
not real and then you know a lot of
times they're uh promoting their Twitter
feed by doing that and why should they
have to pay for that they should just be
able to be popular on their own like
look you did great and you didn't have
to pay people to watch I didn't pay
anybody nothing I didn't pay nobody
that's right
Zach doesn't like that Zach actually
exactly exactly he's a Twitter blue
subscriber shout out yeah but Zach's
okay being a baby too right yeah I'm
your I'm your brother the fans love you
Ethan and they wanted you to uh because
they are uh making you uh you know their
loyal friends and they didn't ask you
that you had to pay them to to watch you
they love you well I don't pay them I
pay Twitter that's right right but this
is the same thing
thank you
um so this was all pretty exciting the
trans or
quartering is having a total meltdown
and I love to see it you know what is
his videos like on his channel during
this time when he's having like a
complete collapse usually he talks about
it but uh this was just last night right
so yeah this is from it's probably still
this morning I mean early this morning
or he might be uh doing a boot and rally
getting ready for a later
the modern that he says the modern right
wing is completely trolled by psyops
they are worse NPCs than the left it
makes you mad that unfollow LOL if you
can't see the obvious then I can't help
you base take actually I couldn't agree
more most of these pundits love [__]
okay now that I'm like taking my pants
off
uh they love drugs and they love
cheating on their spouses that that
actually seems about right on the nose
yeah you want to get mad at me you want
to spurg out in my comments but I've
seen it all right this is why I know
he's lying I've hung out with these
people ain't nobody's hanging out with
the quarter like when have you ever seen
anybody inviting interacting being with
the quartering in person he's 100 lying
uh like genuinely find me a picture of
the quartering literally the only thing
I can think of is those old videos of
him uh doing the claw machines but that
was like that was the last time that was
like a decade ago everything else is in
his his basement and even assume there's
probably some evidence of that
right well that's okay that's exactly
what we're saying let's see uh here
here's his most recent up close that Dr
Anthony fauci has finally caught red
hands he's going to jail dude he's going
to jail wait wait got him is he in the
SS uniform or something what is he
wearing uh
no I think that might be a Russian
uniform actually because he's a
communist oh that would make more sense
so he's a Russian stooge yeah he's like
a Russian soldier like a World War II
Russian soldier
oh no Chris Rock destroys Will Smith
fake woke Corporation Chris Rock torches
wokeness and Will Smith I wouldn't say
he torched weakness I actually watched
it it was a good special I really wanted
to see what Chris had to say about the
Will Smith thing oh yeah and this is the
first time he talked about it it's on
Netflix it was I thought he did it you
thought it you liked it I've been seeing
it get a lot of flack I like the part
about Will Smith
okay well what's the flap that he um
that's hot that he's washed up and not
funny
because he was doing like anti-woke
stuff
I don't know I mean he does I don't know
when these comedians are gonna learn his
opening thing line was like everybody's
gonna be getting triggered tonight
and it's like oh yeah please I know like
I don't think Chris Rock's done a
special in decades and so like he didn't
get the opportunity to get to you know
sink his teeth into that but you guys
gotta drop that it's just not it it's
just so washed up you know yeah that
sentiment was ever funny it's definitely
not anymore maybe it was funny for like
a quarter of a second back in like uh
2001 the word trigger was a deep cut
yeah
I'm going to yeah I'm seeing the chat I
turn it off right away I can't listen to
old men talk about woke anymore yeah
exactly okay so it wasn't as bad as like
Chappelle's in terms of like I I
personally just really wanted to hear
what he said about Will Smith and that
part was was why I was watching and I
thought that part was good because he
really went in on him which I
appreciated for sure you know
but uh it's funny that they say go woke
go broke but all these guys are
definitely washed up and making the
worst content they ever have of course
I'm sure you got paid well though oh
yeah was it so it was uh it was like
actually a live stream yeah Special yeah
they did a live stream on Netflix with
like a pre-show and an after show the
whole thing was like three plus hours
that's interesting
um
it's too bad the special wasn't better
but it's cool that they're doing that
and he kept saying that he uh all these
years that he was a fan of Will Smith's
and right buddies and he kept talking
about how great Will Smith is and you
know he didn't expect that just because
he said that one time on an Academy
Awards with billions of people watching
that Will Smith would you know attack
him like that but I think there was
friction before that time he was dissing
his wife a few times before that he does
address that but he's like dude it was
just like some stupid jokes he had a
really funny joke he goes now I used to
watch emancipation and roof for Will
Smith and now I watch emancipation I go
hit him again Madison God oh my God
that's rough that's it come on that's
funny
well yeah he claims there there wasn't
beef prior in the special he says that
uh Jada got mad because will wasn't
nominated for concussion and then he
said so will gave me a concussion yeah
and Peta he never really defended Jada
as much as he needed to prior to the
Academy Awards there was times when Will
Smith didn't defend his wife and so she
was getting on him to make sure to
defend her that time or any time you
know and she probably was it was built
up that she wanted him to defend her all
these a few for a few times it may be
other comedians had talked about her
alopecia
I just yeah the thing I don't want we
don't need to rehash this is like well
trotted ground but I just don't think
guys don't tell me red button that's
what he said I was saying telling his
joke I didn't use any slurs or anything
I'm going to okay yeah I thought his bit
about the
about it was was fine okay thank you
listen I didn't say that I I when I
watch um
when I watch emancipation I I just sit
in silence in reverence
and I'm all constantly crying throughout
the whole movie
your white ass down and you listen I sit
exactly I sit my white ass down and I
feel guilty and sad
actually I haven't seen this movie to be
totally honest it got [__] reviews
though
I don't even remember this movie it's
from 2000 that was last year yeah
did you see that one Eddie there's a 46
on Rotten Tomatoes even the audience
gave it 55. you knew that was like an
Oscar bait he's like yeah emancipation
okay it was okay
there it is Eddie says it was okay
here we go okay
[Music]
it's not my joke people
I told you I cry when I watch it
I guess not I do Hail Mary what is it
called Hail Mary's uh what what do you
call self flagulation I self-flagulate
when I watch it
not because just not in a reference to
like
slavery but like in a reference to like
how people atone for their sins right
you know what I'm talking about medieval
kind of thing thank you if I originally
in big trouble I played a basketball
player on the original Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air you did in several episodes I
was the basketball player and I got to
dribble ball next in Alfonso Ribeiro and
Will Smith and well you know we were
doing uh College their Prep School
basketball you know and and it was fun
to work on and it was uh he was really
cool to to be you know a rising star at
that time and that's fun that's exciting
I got to work on Enemy of the State and
a few other of his movies so you guys
are friends practically yeah he was a
cool guy you know never had and he was
he was recently on you know that uh the
show with David Letterman or uh Jay Leno
uh where they he talked about Hollywood
and he was coming from The Comedy Store
and telling everybody you know how much
he loved Hollywood right before the
academy hold the phone we have a picture
of you in fresh
[Music]
well they were the prep school kids and
then I was like one of the people you're
not in this photo but I'm not in that
photo but those were the days where I
was up right they're wrong the caption
says it's top right but you're saying
that's not you the guy whose face is
covered that could be me I you know that
doesn't look you think that could be you
no the one in behind the uh this is you
yeah there you are
[Applause]
and I had to take him we had to like we
had a lot of down time so we went to
like eat lunch for some reason at a lot
when we went on location or in the
studio and or in the park and I remember
having to be with that one of these
people and this is yeah I got this
close-up is this do you remember this
moment yeah yeah how come you don't want
me man
you've been you've done it all it really
isn't and I played a football player on
pull Kai for uh Married with Children
for several episodes where it got to be
in like a football uniform and that's
what haven't you done
by the way this is quartering's latest
uh thumbnail he is so [__] insane
like literally it's it's they're just
telling the story as it was written
right I mean yeah that story is the gay
agenda dude
they're doing a faithful retelling of
the story [__] hell
are you all are you are you caught up on
them no I didn't watch the new one yet
[__] was it good did you watch it nope
uh I think Ian did right yeah it's good
Ian's been
he's obsessed I love the show too it
hasn't missed for me yet no I have not
watched uh Attack on Titan yet Abe
neither I was almost in tears it was so
good I'm going to though I'm going I'm
going to
I'm definitely going I took the wind out
of my sails when they this still isn't
the last block of episodes I don't know
why they're doing it like this it's been
the final season for three or four years
yeah and it's not even an exaggeration
it's crazy money yeah seriously
quartering says lots of panic in my DMs
don't care can't wait for tomorrow's
live at 9 A.M we us too but I haven't
seen that
is it in his live tab
could be live stream three days ago
that's his most recent live oh this is
good I think he is sleeping off a
hangover
yo the new fat man bad just dropped oh
let's see it I gained a lot of weight in
my life and since I gained weight people
have been calling me fat a lot oh you
don't look fat to me you think you look
nice and fit and trim your youthful
looking you don't look fat at all thanks
man I appreciate you saying that well
anyway look what this person said Layla
Halpern look at this [__] has inspired
me and really helped me if it wasn't for
him I'd probably be vaccinated boosted
and probably a crazy feminist and
married to a beta male by now so
come on me I'm the poster boy bait of
him I think I look quite dashing in that
photo to be totally honest
wow we look like brothers Ethan
yeah yeah
uh this this person h3c Lord says he
thinks that you were in the room when
they were born wow is that possible
could be could be I was in the room when
they were born I play in an extra oh
yeah one of the nurses I mean dude I'm
really [__] on Tick Tock like a lot of
nurses that day I think I might be
Tick-Tock Enemy Number One thanks kid
thanks bro love you well for this corner
of it inspired me and really helped me
if it wasn't for him vaccinated I love
that my brother inspired me not to get
vaccinated boosted to drop out of high
school to stop to eat only meat to uh
recycle my feces and to edible uh Power
Bars to drink my own to drink my own
fermented urine she has a few videos uh
defending Tate saying that they hung out
together once and he was a gentleman oh
yeah there's dub there's Peaks valleys
our streaming computer had a
I don't know man it turned out it just
it fully crashed Ian said uh his uh
it made like a loud buzzing noise and uh
got a bunch of error messages all of a
sudden and then it just shut itself off
so we'll do it live we'll probably want
to look into that after the show that's
not something that's happened before Ian
said it it went
computers aren't supposed to make sounds
generally yeah
okay but we're back everything's good uh
it looks like we are back oh yeah it's
fantastic thank you guys thank you to
the quick work of the team there and um
if everyone could refresh just Spam
refresh in the comments people know
right Eddie right
excuse me so anyway what were we talking
about oh this lady
yeah we were saying that she is a tate
uh
a tate writer a tate writer tater tot
tater tot oh speaking of Andrew Tate I
feel like we were the only real
journalism in the game on Friday we
reported he does not have cancer as
always and nobody else talked about it
until like freaking Sunday unbelievable
you know it's a non-story we called it
from the beginning shut up you shut up
you shut up idiot shut up you're in
prison dork far more fun shut up idiot
I have small dick energy I knew that and
it's true
I'm probably a crazy feminist and
married to a beta male fight
brutal brutal I was looking so fly in
that outfit I got all pink I puffed out
my chest that's what they say you do
when you want to present like your Alpha
energy without your chest so I was doing
all the right things hmm it's just that
the camera angle got you at the wrong
angle you probably didn't look that big
it's just the side
how was that big and your face didn't
look that bad it looks exactly the same
as it does oh thank you so much for
saying that that really you look young
there thank you thank you wow it's just
the way the pants were were holding or
the way the Hat was or things like that
100 percent
they're just trying to get an
unflattering picture of you but you
would I do believe I did post that photo
myself oh you did yeah okay
let's see what she's saying let's see
what this uh genius has to say about
topics happened you know let's see uh we
all get a little bit of weight weapons
Matrix
I'll be at home with kids okay let's see
how she's a subservient female we love
those
tell me about how much of a
perfect woman that I can look up to and
I can respect you know I think the world
of him that would be amazing he can then
continue our mission like I don't need
to be out on the front line he can be
out on the front line I'll be home with
the kids but knowing that like something
which I care about which is creating a
better world empowering mentally men
women to be women because I think that's
how people are happiest I'm knowing that
my husband is pushing that narrative
forward is enough for me my ideal
scenario is to meet a man that I can
look up to and I can respect you know I
think the world of him that would be
amazing the title is Lay Leia on meeting
a respectable alpha male
she's just part of the Griff she's like
she's just like a little parasite that
tags onto the tape thing where she's
like yeah no he's right man women women
are [__] pathetic we are just idiots
to be used
swimming be shopping baby and um there's
a few women I've noticed that are doing
this hopping on this
just pearly things what is it Pearl
Pearl yeah
but I love their their perspective is
really great no we suck he's right we're
all horrible
different perspectives
which is really interesting for that I
wonder how much women she has in her
Audience by the way
because like her content's for women
right
you inspire women right so why is it
that your demo is like 99 man
it's interesting I mean I'm assuming I
don't know what her demo is but you know
I'm right
I'm trying to find a really out of
pocket one let's see there's nothing
sexist almost misogynistic about saying
my women it's a beautiful thing would it
be sexist if a woman said my husband
what the [__] are you talking about what
is this premise nobody's mad about that
my wife my wife
she or maybe what the [__] are you
saying No
this is my women if something belongs to
you we're gonna look up this is like me
being like hey I'm just gonna say it
it's okay to say I love my wife and I
don't care what conservatives say I
could smoke marijuana conservatives say
your wife guy
am I a white guy a wife guy
I
no being a wife guy is gay
that's what they would say yeah
yeah
um
I say I love my wife and kids and I
don't care if Republicans say that I
shouldn't respect my wife I just respect
her and I love her even though all
Republicans say I should spit in her
face and make her walk behind me
never talk about my wife and people are
saying you're totally a wife guy I'm
sorry no I am a wife guy I agree oh well
what does that mean I don't talk about
my wife all the time why are you worried
about because wife guy wife guys are
cheaters wife guys right we established
that with um no Ned yeah Ned yeah right
Ned Flanders
who killed his wife if I remember on
accident
um
let's see wait didn't Ned kill his wife
she died but I don't think he didn't
kill her yeah no she got shot off the
stands by a T-shirt cannon oh it was a
t-shirt yeah some Simpsons lore for
everybody
yeah
hey
that bad where it belongs
so thank you to her I got my big red
boots
my mom could not believe me that these
cost 350 dollars and that they're like
she was so freaking confused by this
there's a video somewhere Ela took so
I do you like the boots they're
unwearable okay it's more like I think
they're a cool like display piece like
an art piece they look really cool as a
wearable shoe it's not it's insane I
mean I couldn't even walk down the
stairs because I was I felt like I was
getting a trip it's really there's a
boot inside
whoa and then it's just covered with
plastic there's a boot on the bottom I
mean it's constructed pretty well to be
fair to them bullets because
they did send me two left shoes
not that it matters I guess because I'm
not going walking but but wait what some
people would prefer Alexa right you paid
350 for two left seats I did stupid
Astro Boy looking shoes no these are
Collectibles I think don't say that
about that yeah shut the [__] up Dad
yeah what's wrong are you just upset you
don't have them I bet oh yeah that's
true I'm Jealous by the way Jimmy did a
live
and this this man pays people to do that
to him oh my God you see that hairline
oh
like holy smokes Jimbo Jimbo my man
yeah I think they're cool I like them
actually
I gotta find you can find that video of
my mom like tripping out oh you did
thank you here
posted a story
[__] baby no
oh
Instagram putting on audio for me
YouTube does that too with the shorts
come on I just noticed that when you
loaded that last video
my mom thought I was lying to her that I
was yanking her chain
actually
this is
Ela rocks it Mickey Mouse ass looking
really they look awesome
no
that shot of you and Bruce it's so cute
someone posted on Reddit yeah he's cute
he he crawled up to me on the stairs and
he's so sweet lately he's just so sweet
oh he looks really okay he was up to
something
really up to something here since
Shredder got sick we had to change his
diet completely wow and now he loves
bell pepper
okay and he loves watermelon
and before when he was on his like all
meat diet being a little punk this is so
cute I love them so much
they um he wouldn't touch this stuff he
wouldn't dream of eating a bell pepper
so he's he's unhealthy he's a healthy
boy now
he's doing good
this picture yeah he's so cute got a
little bit of a camel [__] tough
going on there it's a little
embarrassing we call that the Schwab now
the Schwab no it's not that bad no not
that bad
the Schwab is like a meat sandwich yeah
it's ultimate moose like Saran wrapped
the hell yeah Italian deli style [__]
yeah
what what do you want to say Amy about
it yeah tackled Titans yeah some people
are still talking about it in chat and I
just want to say that I found out last
week that uh Matt Mercer who voices Levi
is actually
um his wife is in the crater clash with
me and uh
Marisha
Marisha yeah does she have a last name
she does it's a a beautiful last name
um Mercer right aren't they married
are they just boyfriends no they are
married yes are Marisha Ray okay yeah so
so her husband is the voice actor for
Levi yeah and he's gonna most likely I'm
guessing gonna be at the fight he may be
we're in the same launch so are you
you're a Stan of his I am now Levi is
Levi's babies guy yeah I know but he's
just a voice actor he's not actually no
but listen to that is this them yeah
he's not actually fighting giant mutants
yeah I think we get that
yeah I'm just saying he's gonna
potentially be in my locker room did you
just admit to admitting to the dub I
mean if if he Hypes me up I gotta ask
him I gotta ask him
fake weeaboo
if he gives me a talk in Levi's voice
that's it it's game over
who's she fighting
uh uh let me see a dead woman
that's not much of a fight
she's also died uh opponent
Clash
he is fighting Haley
okay oh wow hmm
that'll be interesting Haley's a
seasoned Pro
right she fought last time viciously
heroically even and she's a fan I hate
to say but I'm gonna have to root
against her because Haley's a fan we
even did a Teddy fresh shoot with her
I gotta find out if she's a fan because
if she's not then death I mean well
not that far but uh I wish her I wish
she loses
and I oop die you fan of Wendy Williams
oh yeah I used to be but then when she
started to get a little weird towards
the end I stopped watching her talk show
as much but you know I was a big fan of
hers what do you mean weird well you
know when she had her uh kind of metal
breakdowns right in the middle of the
show and she kind of uh was doing that
thinking that she could make more money
doing a podcast than she would be doing
her talk show that was the deal breaker
because you know it's but I was uh
hoping that she would come out with that
podcast and you know had nothing yeah
yeah we were just talking about it last
week are you are you in deep kind of
like the whoop whoop are you in that
deep yeah I thought she was you know had
a good story going would you do that if
you were in the audience because they
all go yeah I probably would you would
yeah
you did the game just now you didn't
actually just do Wendy's wait you're
right wait what did they say
he Eddie said it like Wendy hey how you
doing how you doing oh my God you're
right I said it like this Gabe is like
yeah
oh [__] all right well let's talk about
Mr Beast okay um let's actually do our
ads first okay because we're gonna yeah
we're at 40 minutes so let me thank our
lovely sponsors then we'll get into our
main segment here with about Mr BEAST's
chocolate being violated on the shelves
and we know that no we cannot allow
blemish on Mr beast's name
hell no he's the best of us
he's the only true human being that
matters
I bend the knee too he gives people
money he's curing blind people yeah dude
he's turning water into wine he's
walking on it yeah he's Jesus he's
literally he's
Jesus Christ
came back to life yep dude he's better
than Jesus [__] Jesus Jesus never gave
someone a [__] bro
what
show did you never gave anybody a
Ferrari idiot he's beastless
he didn't have Walmart exclusive cookies
you know what Jesus would be a
contestant on Mr Beast hoping for a
[__] Ferrari yeah you'd be in the
squid games Jesus is at what Jesus is at
Walmart fixing the display
for Mr Beast
all right let's thank our sponsors
first up the one and only
I drink it every day it's Gamer sucks
it's hydrating
it doesn't have sugar so it's slimming
if you're drinking sugary drinks stop
stop it right now that's one of the
worst things you could do
get this
it's got electrolytes it's got caffeine
it's a straight blast off
and I and it's the best way to get this
day started for me oh that just went
right through my ears I heard that yes
sorry it just I got me all
got me all excited
I love gamer Subs so much man
this is the black cherry I ride for the
black cherry
oh there's so many flavors though
honestly you could
all different flavors Zach
what's that there's so many flavors
that's different I gotta explain the
music out of that machine oh you can't
do yeah we gotta we gotta upgrade our
Tech man
I need Jimmy Lee during my Gamers maybe
he could uh oh I'll add it to the other
thing in fact you could use um you could
use the Scorpion chair and you could
have a bunch of monitors right yeah
exactly you need a scorpion chair I do
need a scoreboard okay let's try it I
got you
maybe I can get you a different animal
like uh
no no a lion a lion chair yeah he could
have this one you don't you know that's
your chair Dan I wouldn't I wouldn't
dream of it I got problems then I got
problems
how many times you farted on that thing
you expect Zach to sit in there I would
never I would never disrespect the chair
in that way
if Aiden Ross was here he'd smell the
[__] out of that scorpion chair
hmm
Gamers up
so good I actually love this drink I I
feel so much better since I started
drinking every day instead of coffee I
like coffee but sometimes
it's a very acidic you know and if you
need your caffeine hit the gamer stuff
is just like a really good way to get it
to hydrate it kind of does all these
nice things for you they also have a
mobile app where all drops will be
accessible 20 minutes early through the
app moving forward download the mobile
app and get early access to the waifu
cups because they always sell out on the
site quickly
what's up with our waifu cup I know
we've been working on one I'm just
waiting on updates uh they're in the
flavor lab
right they're in the flavor lab I'm
really happy we we're working on our own
waifu cup and the graphic I think came
out really nice yeah
it tastes great
there's so many flavors you could
honestly try so many before and before
you find your favorite I think I
personally find that fun that they have
so much variety no sugar won't break a
fast or take you out of ketosis
as you know that's important to me I'm
I'm buzzing with Kato in a state of
ketosis
it's like a flow state
Special K baby the meat goes in
Tranquility comes out
also uh if if you don't want caffeine
they have caffeine free versions so if
you just want a nice hydrating tasty
beverage there's that too you want a
gamer sub we can make one for sure you
guys want to cook up a gamer sub for
Eddie caffeine free you want caffeine
yeah caffeine free or without without
okay okay let's give it a shot cool
[Applause]
um
yeah I love it they have metal cups
that's cool
oh you don't have it I love it man if
you guys still haven't tried the free
sample we've been giving away for weeks
you still can
if you have ordered them in the last
month they won't send out another one
because they're gonna go broke
but you can always pick up a flavor that
you liked using Code H3 for a discount
so if you want a free pack I can't
emphasize how free this is the sample go
to
gamersupps.gg H3 links in description
get your free sample pack for the next
24 hours listen to this all you have to
do is add it to the cart hit checkout
enter your mailing address and enter
your email and your mailing address and
your email address you don't even have
to add a credit card your total will be
zero dollars they will send you a free
sample to your house all right that now
that's an offer that is enough it's like
you don't even have to put in your
credit card unbelievable go try the
black cherry that's my faves yeah
I love that one so if you missed the 24
hour window you can still always use
code H3 for 10 off your order so man I
love gamersup thank you and thank you
for supporting them they're they're a
great sponsor we love them so thank you
and next up we have honey
I love me some money folks
shopping on the internet without honey
is like walking around
with your hands cut off your eyes closed
and your ears plugged
hmm
because
with honey
on the internet you have all of your
senses heightened
uh you'll be in a state of euphoric
jubilation
wow thank you
yeah because Honey's it's a two you
takes two clicks it's a free extension
uh for your browser
and what it does is when you check out
your favorite store
it automatically applies the best coupon
it can find a checkout I've saved so
much money with this without a second
thought you kind of you don't even think
about it it really is incredible I every
week we're saving fifty dollars ten
dollars five dollars that I never would
have saved
without it
um also comes uh exciting you can
download it on the iPhone now too just
activate it on Safari on your phone save
on the go so now you can do it on your
desktop and your phone
and so
yeah when I get a new browser the first
thing I do is install honey because I
buy a lot of stuff online uh-huh and
it's on so many websites you just go to
checkout boom it does that drop down say
check for coupon and it's like these are
all savings that we in this office have
done amazing thank you Eddie it is
amazing isn't it
I love it yeah and so basically
that's how it works you just wait a few
seconds honey searches for the coupon
and boom bada bing It's Magic oh thank
you wait not yet yeah don't don't hit
that yet oh yeah or you can hit it yet
but oh let's wait yeah it's just for
moved on we can do it after this whoa
this cuff is awesome what the hell yeah
yo what this cup is sick baby
yeah I'll show it off after this
yeah man I'm talking close tech gadgets
Pizza food you know duvet covers
furniture
literally everything
um
pull up a one that that was from
I don't know recent one I'm sure Ela
sends them in all the time
yeah if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting the show
so that's really nice thank you get
PayPal honey for free at joinhoney.com
h3tv that's joinhoney.com h3tv yeah
here's one we saved 20 bucks
on 120 purchase I mean it's it's
ridiculous dude stop it we love you
honey thank you for sponsoring me
thank you Chrissy Sherlock by the way
yeah this cut this is uh we got Eddie's
drink oh I guess it's kind of keying out
but here you go dude this is sick it's
true here you want to hit it all right
caffeine free what flavor you got there
that's uh titty milk titty milk is that
okay
that's really good this is delicious
and then you feel you feel the hydration
this course thing I love sugar well that
is really good
you got it
you drink that titty milk
thank you yeah no it's fantastic it's
such a great product I mean where would
we be without gamer sub thank you yeah
so um all right let's talk about the
Beast the Beast Within
you love me some all right so actually I
feel like we TR we're a little bit ahead
of the curve on this one I went I was
taking a I was using the restroom I was
doing a number two during the show I
don't like to do that but sometimes it
just happens because we do a long show
and I was on Twitter grumpy I was making
a grumpy and uh I saw this this was
right Dan I mean I I feel like we were
the we're the first one to talk about
this can I get a little respect once
again breaking the news what are we
talking about oh I was following up with
the response yes yes you you broke the
news don't say it patronizing baby you
know what I was trying to back you up
but no but it sounds like you're
patronizing me no I wasn't you so you
really think I broke the news yeah I do
and I got news for you that means you're
gay
what what news did you break I've sent
this tweet in our group chat while I was
taking a dump on Friday and we were the
first people to talk about how what a
kind of a crazy tweet it was I love it
over I got no respect around here no
respect anyway he said I need your help
next time you see feastables at Walmart
and soon to be in new retailers could
you clean up the presentation and make
it look better that'd be make me very
happy I need I want to make Jimmy happy
make Jimmy anything for you Jimmy
I'm building a team to do this routinely
just need help in the short term
well you needed a team you got it Jimmy
here's a before not good we do not like
this no the bars are everywhere oh it's
upside down there's no respect they're
all like clumpy they're they're sagging
here to Jimmy no Mr Beast he deserves
better now now that's what I'm talking
about that's better oh that looks good
that's a display that looks good
and so he has mobilized
his dude I'm pretty sure if Jimmy called
a hit that person would be dead in like
five minutes
listen
I walked through the ralves to this
morning or the Walmart
and the chocolate balls they were a
little
uncapped
and so
Walmart on 23 Topanga Boulevard
something my things have bad things
happen all the time to managers at
Walmart stores
just last week a manager from a Walmart
store had a horrible crash
passed away tragic kids now I turned
into Trump I forgot
to do The Godfather angels in this we
come to the Walmart and [__] what
happened more De Niro try the dinero
route
no why not because I'm no it's got to be
it's a significance I think you got like
cotton swabs in your mouth okay
you come you come today to the Walmart
that's better no is that better yeah
it's like it's like
kill the music for a second let's talk
like I really mean it you know like just
uh mean it like really uh Michael
Jackson used to say he would only sing
songs if he meant it so like just act
you are meaning it but just put more me
like you really mean it and then that
and you could do any kind of acting
character you know what's funny Michael
Jackson has a lyric where he goes don't
Jew me so I guess he really meant that
one huh yeah
but I do wonder he said man I wonder if
he meant Man in the Mirror when he says
I'm looking he says yeah a problem I
wonder if he did that was a little funny
yeah
good I mean I love his music though yeah
fantastic music right baby
yeah
he's a big fan what's in your mouth you
doing dick or something oh no he's
method acting right now I was about to
mess up oh
you're preparing yeah we come we come to
this Walmart today
because we've found out over the twitch
of that
some of the cases were a little
disheveled
and
this is a message to the manager at
Walmart
terrible things happen to the managers
all the time
you broke my heart I lost it
boy boy
hit me with the original Godfather
the original Godfather you know that
[__] Martin
Marlon Brando thank you Marlon Brando
with impersonation do you have a sound
bite of him
I was playing Michael
yeah no I know I know
[Music]
but the Godfather the real Godfather is
Brando right come to me on the night
well that's good you come to me tonight
yeah see yeah yeah there you go Moana
setup bonus that is not Justice that's
not Justice
I can't remember the last time then
there it is here
we come I come before you today in this
Walmart
as a man who's been disrespected
a man who's been slighted head for what
I've done so much for you at Walmart
the hordes they come in they buy things
and here I am being disrespected
on the day of a when I cared a hundred
thousand people's blindness
now Jacob Smith manager of the Walmart I
know it was you
you broke my heart
and I will say the day may come maybe
not today
maybe not the next day but Justice will
come to you
you got it Godfather
not as good as that that's right let's
hear what you got you're the actor here
well I haven't really done any of those
Godfather wins but I was in a music
video where I played like a mafia type
and we recreated the whole Godfather
scene and I was eating some spaghetti
and I can't remember the name of that
but it was with the famous rapper and I
uh got to be in that uh do you have an
impression or no no not at the moment
thank you yeah Eddie's the perfect side
man he wouldn't want to upstairs I
wouldn't want to Upstate you you were
terrific that was uh I'd have to say
incredible you're a good man Eddie
you're a good man
you've always supported me
we're gonna have to recast
called Coppola man
anyway where were we were talking about
so here Greg
at Walmart just cleared the shove Greg
you have no shame brother
just clean the shelf for you Mr Beast
he's not gonna [__] you dude
in this case he's not gonna send you 10
grand dude that's what they think right
I'm sending ten thousand dollars to a
random person that fixes my display
which is actually funny because like to
pay that many people would cost a lot of
money to have people just like 24 hours
Stand by Your display that's a [__]
stamp that's why we're doing a pro bono
hey if they pay me once I get over to
the Walmart and fix that I'll donate the
money to a charity right oh yeah it's
convenience well you work for the best
because that's what Mr Beast always does
right isn't anyways well I guess not
charity he's just giving it to random
people so wait we haven't I'll give it
to Ethan we have an album
of um college fund for the two kids
I got a bunch of um
uh
pictures of these simps actually going
out there and sending pictures
uh the person said Mr that's just the
photos that Mr Beast posted I think that
guy's joking
huh look at Mr BEAST's uh yeah I saw but
it is real stuff happening uh Mr Beast
unlocked a new form of capitalism I hate
it here so here's his and here's the
Sims they're actually out there doing it
I fixed the aisle at Walmart let's be
Frank Frank
this is embarrassing for you brother
Maybe not maybe he's doing good maybe
he's doing a good thing why are you why
are you maybe he's doing a good deed
he's beautifying changing the world man
like [__] you know
this is a good way to spend your time
I think
soup kitchens they're overstaffed
yeah but but clearly there's nobody
fixing the displays yeah
mm-hmm
congratulations he's not gonna [__] you
Frank
there's a lone wolf Michigan's at the
Walmart so your chocolate bar fits them
properly anything for the team
that's what it is they it's the team
thing right yeah the uh the Beast
Brigade right or we mess them up first
and we then fix them after we mess them
all up and then that way nobody would
know that they were
[Applause]
perfectly Planet he says I even bought
the chocolate this man went all out not
only did he fix it he bought it he's
paying Jimmy to do to fix this one no
that chocolate rules
yeah you've been consistent on that
point
did we ever get the my nuts Deez Nuts
these nuts right I'm not sure
I mean it would be kind of funny for
Jimmy because people would Bobble his
nuts does anyone would you like my nuts
if if they have it there I'll make sure
to get his nuts for you thank you
Chrissy Sherlock you are an absolute
Legend thank you so much
um did we get these I believe Sam
reordered it after they sent us the
wrong one and we just haven't received
it yet we didn't get a refund for the
wrong one
well we probably did are they probably
just replacing it I just curious It's
what Sam I want to know about the
customers you get our money back
she's not here
yeah I want to know maybe someone could
text her
thank you
uh so yeah congratulations here
we got the ladies in on it we were just
in Walmart and notice this display
needed some fixing
ha look how she puts the before and
after picture of her face like all
depressed and sad dad says she's really
getting into it you know like brown and
then happy face you're so right and this
display actually looks impeccable I mean
imagine you're walking through Walmart
and you see someone just fixing up the
display of I mean that he really is
humiliating you guys I'm sorry
he's turned you what has he done to
these people's brains
it's just what what is he turning on
Jimmy right now
I love him the Beast Brigade to rise up
in the chat right now no no I would
never be I wouldn't know where she's
going beast mode I would Jimmy's like
BTS I would never yeah let's get the
beast mode venugrate him look at the
chat I I did this before the show I
think it would be coming out hard for
Jimmy yeah I do think sourcing Free
Labor is a little bit sus shame
but you know Jimmy he means well
he means well he wants his chocolate is
important he wants the people to have
his chocolate maybe he thinks also the
workers there at Walmart might just
throw them in the shelves you know if
they're not like a Walmart product but
he wants his to stand out you know
amongst all the Walmart type of Brands
right or the cheaper Brands and he
thinks he needs to be in a year yeah or
something like that
maybe he's trying to help them trying to
help the Walmart workers make it easier
that's it he's trying to help the
Walmart workers yeah he did
unfortunately he did also say oh and
also can you push the other brands away
from my [__] didn't he say that yeah
yeah wait where's that he so he deleted
it because it was very unfortunate
timing
um he said it wasn't other brands it was
specifically Hershey's and
coincidentally Hershey's had that ad
campaign uh that featured uh yeah there
was a cold culture award thing yeah here
she right that I think was like the
whole domain the whole news cycle
exactly and so people took it as he was
dogging on Hershey's for that campaign
or maybe he just doesn't like Walmart
and you know he thinks that he had to
settle for a certain big Corporation but
maybe he wanted it more like you know
the bigger nicer grocery stores that are
more you know upscale like Los Angeles
because he's worth 105 million dollars
so you checked yeah I saw it on Google
he's 105 million might be worth more
than that if I'm being totally honest
but partial responds to backlash over
women's day campaign featuring trans
activists
that story came out like the same day
and then he was like everybody go throw
all the Hershey's on the ground and
stomp on them do you think that was a
coincidence or I think I assume it was a
coincidence I don't think he would want
to get involved in that and that's why
he deleted it he's been [__] on her
juice for a while so yeah I mean yeah
right that's his right but very very
poor timing he said and while you're at
it if you want to maybe move some
Hershey bars and make sure feastfuls has
plenty of space I wouldn't complain
that's 100 a real request
and you know because of the crazy face
yep
so um
you know
well it's not Bed Bath and Beyond Mr
Beast you know maybe he's thinking you
know they have to have a special counter
right in front of the store when they
walk in just for Mr Beast and they could
do that maybe he should say maybe he
should take it further if you all could
move chocolate bars and pile them up at
the entrance for me and they have space
for that they could do that there is a
table like this table there right when
you walk in and they always put special
little products there okay that's a good
idea or things so we could ask them if
they maybe we should say hey guys can
you please stand in front of the store
with a box of Mr bees and actively sell
them to people
um Brandon says I make 70 000 a year
doing this for a certain soda brand
going around fixing sodas wow so that's
actually a really I mean expensive uh
operation for someone to do that well
he's also frustrated that he can't go
into every single Walmart and do that
himself well he's gotta he should be
hiring people right are you you're
trying to get you're trying to get Jimmy
to give you some money aren't you yeah
why any time you know I'd love to uh
make that ten thousand dollars uh if he
wants to uh donate it to me I could use
uh that for down payment I would
absolutely love to see the shirtless
Eddie in a beast video I think you'd we
can make that happen we can make that
yeah but it's a friend of the show
um you know you might seize um some
Teddy fresh left over at Zumiez if you
guys could just
um basically
just
yeah just uh redress the mannequins in
the windows please just a little favor
all Teddy fresh
thank you and if you want to toss around
the Thrasher merch I won't complain yeah
if you guys want to if you guys want to
shoplift the thresh armor that'd be I
wouldn't I wouldn't say anything
yeah if you if you guys want to pretend
to be employees there and move and show
people to the teddy fresh uh Iowa
wouldn't complain
it's awesome
but he has that good will I don't think
anyone else has that good will
or they could be like work for free for
me and they'd be like AI captain
pretty incredible
what can't he do so that's what's going
on there there was a lot of uh what
Heights can't he reach
slavery
it's like he's he's made slavery cool
and that and we that hasn't happened in
hundreds of years right you know
Innovation maybe ever maybe ever yeah
yeah perhaps yeah maybe it was never
cool yeah yeah maybe it was never cool
was slavery ever cool Eddie no no no no
no no no
no it was yeah give it up
uh there were some really funny uh memes
going around though in response I caught
this man after he bumped into a
feastable display at Walmart I'm slowly
poisoning him with gas and he's begging
for his life
shall I finish him officer and oh [__]
that's funny
Mr Beast I will continue destroying your
chocolate the space until you pay me a
hundred thousand dollars see now he uh
he turned he played with fire maybe a
little too close to the Sun there
um Mr Beast I caught this man after his
shoulder brushed a feasible display and
one of your chocolate fell on the ground
he is pleading for Mercy but I do not
believe he's truly sorry I should like
deal with them
uh this is fun man oh yeah I caught this
bed every moment into a peaceful display
at Walmart I beat him on the street and
he's on life support shall I pluck
should I pull the plug sir
where's the Jay Leno one oh God can we
get one with Jay Leno I want to craft my
own tweet with that picture of him in
the hyperbolic chamber
Mr Beast I I put a car bomb on Jay
Leno's gas tank after he after
he
passed gas near a feasible display right
I caught this man after he bumped into a
feastable display at the Shadow Moses
I'm slowly running a high voltage
electric current through him what the
[__] I have no idea what metal gear
solid okay okay that's a deep cut
yeah and of course Jimmy is responsible
we encouraged that one yeah he says do
what must be done
Mr Beast the fourth Mr Beast feastful
display destroyed today eight Walmarts
they go okay you also need it live bro
you really need a life brother
so this is my point though there's a
it's a war ground at Walmart and right
Mr Beast display some people are
protecting it some people are attacking
it it's just a full-on bloodbath over
there in the candy aisle
and so us being a loyal soldiers to the
cause as you know
and undying supporters of Mr Beast and
all he does for the world
we are sending our Walmart crack troops
yeah our Walmart experts shirtless Eddie
to protect and guard I'm ready will you
protect the display with your life I
will protect it with my life yes you
protect it from All Things foreign
and domestic will you fight tooth nail
blood spit and sperm to protect those
displays yes sir yes
beautiful line read you what you need
and if anybody comes in like a five feet
radius you have to ask I'm gonna I gotta
stop you there and ask are you here for
the feasible bars yes or no if they say
yes then you taking a handy to them as
to not destroy the beautiful display oh
just make sure well do yeah that's smart
that's smart We Will Never Surrender
Never Surrender we will never resil we
will always resist
[Music]
the Halloween discount aisle
I believe an individual citizen in this
country has a right to own a nuclear
warhead we will fight in the parking lot
we will
if the manager attempts to kick us out
we will say no no
no no we should actually respect the
employees and if they ask us to leave we
should politely take okay we're gonna
first tell them you're with Mr Beast yes
if they try to kick you out just it's
calmly explain if they try to kick you
out we will calmly explain that we are
part of the Beast Brigade
this whole episode
bring this with you Eddie so people know
you mean business
stand there like the kingsguard Alex
Nick my face with the [__] sword
shield
this whole episode I've been rehearsing
in my head how I'm gonna deal with
Walmart management and I don't know how
I'm gonna approach this but I'll wing it
yeah you'll be fine what was the name of
that guy who's destroying his displays
go down to the bottom
I got a message for you
hey
josher I got a message hey Joshua I got
a message for you from the box he says
you come around to this the Beast
displays I got a little special
something for you it's called steel
don't you get it
it's called steel and blade you
understand while sucking a smoker Fire
and Ice
I'll meet you in the Frozen aisle of
teach about Fire and Ice watching a
wiener now Eddie I've got this uh
special
Mr Beast uh Brigade badge may come over
there and tape it to your Chichi Sure
hold on you're Chichi it would be my
honor yes we have these special badges
made so that if the employees do
approach us they'll know that we are not
there to cause trouble imaginable we are
there to maintain the Integrity of the b
style badge of honor let's see Eddie now
that um
it looks beautiful in these things
what does it say
it says security Beast Brigade a fish
officer officer Eddie officer shirtless
Eddie and here hold this take this be
careful Eddie be careful it is a real
sword
so you'll take that with you as a
Weaponry no Vanguard thank god well
don't use it you just be intimidating
only use it if you have to okay no
blades in the Walmart
The Last Resort it's the last resort I'm
ready whoa
so
yeah can you turn it so we can see the
full thing on camera oh yes yeah you see
this [__] hey Joshua take a look at
what we send in your way
so you can see it
we got a beast oh hell oh
a beast hey Jimmy oh wait no it's a
beast take a look I got a little
something for you it's called steel you
understand
these chocolate bars are worth more than
your life
I'd rather spill blood than chocolate
you know what I'm saying
hmm I'm willing to die for this cause
yeah I pledge myself
to a beast
I'm cutting my hand this is I'm doing a
Blood Oath
oh God
tastes like chocolate
that's right I believe
it tastes like feastable you understand
only four ingredients there's only four
simple ingredients you get it
Blood Sweat and Tears Blood Sweat tears
and semen you understand
we're very rapidly um kind of
vacillating between the military theme
of this whole thing and the yeah
Godfather we gotta pick a gotta pick a
thing
I shall I also yeah medieval wait give
me the Walmart aisle again
we I shall I shall Patrol the aisles of
Walmart looking for Traders to the Beast
army they shall be impaled and their
heads put on a spike
when you walk on the candy aisle you
will see heads on swipes of those
Traders blood will drench the flow of
that aisle can we get a pickup in aisle
three we got blood
clean up you can never clean the blood
that I spill for the enemies of Mr Beast
shall [__] die and torment in pain
and they shall suffer
guy warhorn
oh give me send me like a whole speech
there Abby yeah I got you we will not go
quietly into the night speeches this
hype speech
[Music]
when supplies are low we shall eat
chocolate when water is low we shall eat
chocolate
when times are hard we shall eat
and when the chocolate's gone
then I shall eat my comrades
because I will not fail Mr Beast
ever what the hell was that
Ethan will not fail ever I love that
Jimmy
sees himself on the screen and jumps
into outfit I love that
okay where okay can I get a speech here
I'm I'm typing I'm I'm typing I'm typing
it up a little bit um copy paste how
long is this uh Speech because you know
just copy paste from like Independence
Day or something okay it's half it's
half it's half edited so here you go
it's hard to keep the energy up this
long you know well I'm trying to Hype go
ahead
and half of it will make sense we're
fighting
feel like the moment's gone
thank you for a right to you to eat
chocolate to exist should we win the
win the Super March will be as the day
when the world decided in one voice we
will not go quietly Into the Night
I was trying to
fools
for the Shire all right so you guys get
the importance of what we're doing yes
we will do that and if if you see anyone
bump it do you tell them we have a
hyperbole hyperbaric chamber with their
name on it right right
you've seen Jay Leno in that hyperbaric
chamber can you pull that up
that's going to be maybe we should print
that out and just say this could be you
if you [__] with us wrong
all right so so with that all being said
I think Jimmy and cam this is your cue
to head out got it now there's about
five Walmarts within like 30 minute
driving we'll rush over there so we're
just gonna hit as many as we can right
let's do it that's right
exciting yep
hey here's Jay Leno
Jaylen on Wikipedia here is it
hyperbatch chamber
and you know what you know what people
say it was a an accident with his heart
no he [__] he brushed a Mr Beast
display right
how can someone take he said it was mid
he said the chocolate was mid so I'm
really excited to see the state of the
displays yeah and just to see all the K
you know I'm I'm expecting there's just
going to be people like in camo with
paintball guns and [__] and like netted
camo netting
it's gonna be a bloodbath
all right so um
I'm ready good luck godspeed all right
thank you godspeed soldiers we'll see
you on the way out what soldiers united
we will be there we will be there you
look nice uh you look like have you lost
more weight yeah another two pounds good
for you Eddie thank you I noticed thank
you you look good brother thank you so
much all right good luck out there
how's your punch you do a good punch
Eddie you good okay good I gouge you do
any of those yeah he's not gonna need
that the eye gouge I I don't think I'll
need that you you know about this if
they do the eye gouge protection you can
do what you've switched to one poke one
poke so if you could actually do two
um you can go round in a flanking
maneuver yeah perfect The Three Stooges
yeah I learned that from a great General
named Mo okay oh [__] Eddie
We Salute You
we honor you and if you die in the field
we shall never forget you think in the
middle of that you called Eddie I think
you got I did Mr piston everybody's
Jimmy at this in this battle he's like
we are like uh agent Smith Mr Beast will
be all of us Ukraine is such [__] we
need to be sending our resources to
protecting Jimmy Lee
Mr Beast uh candy display
[Music]
whoa
so this is exciting so once they're
there we'll get a call in and uh report
so guys thank you so much Cam and Eddie
they're out there going out there into
the world good luck Godspeed
he'll be shirtless of course
as he always is all right I hope so
it's got a little point
[Music]
hmm
so there it is thank you all right
moving on
Kenneth nopland
got him do you mean I'll help there
there's like a saying about how like uh
the Devil comes in the form of a angel
or like there's all these kind of
Christian sayings about like evil people
appearing as good right the Antichrist
and so you look at a guy like Kenneth
Copeland the man's Hellfire shines from
behind his eyes this man is like evil
yep
he's just so evil this is the guy who I
mean we've talked about him a lot he's
probably the most psychotic of like the
prosperity preachers
and he was he kind of made a splash when
he did this really terrible interview
with I think it was like date or East
Side Edition yeah Inside Edition yeah
and they're like tell me why exactly you
need a 200 million dollar jet
and so for some for whatever reason he's
addressing it now like 10 15 years later
oh I just assumed this was like a on
Unearthed clip
I don't know I mean I would have
imagined I would have seen it but maybe
you're right yeah I I think Dan's right
yeah I think it's Unearthed so I it's
Unearthed it's on earth like a tap like
a like a commandment it's Indiana Jones
found it in the lost it was lost in the
Dead Sea Caverns right
dinosaurs
the greatest trick the devil ever pulled
was convincing the world he didn't exist
isn't that the usual suspects or is that
it sure is
is that Lit is it does that predate
Usual Suspects no I believe that's a
line from the film that's a great usual
sex love that movie
it's a good one but anyway director and
star of it or uh both P words but I know
Kevin Spacey is what's his name uh
singer
I think that was his first film did he
write it
I don't remember okay hold on I gotta
know about this Brian Seeger someone I
talk about a lot he's like the biggest
pedo in the uh uh no Christopher McCory
wrote it uh he just directed it but yeah
that was uh I believe he's like I can't
watch that anymore because like I'm on a
full person not a Brian Singer who I
think now is kind of out of work people
started to pick up on like yeah they're
not hiring him anymore although he did
just like Direct
Bohemian Rhapsody yeah that was uh that
was five years ago now let me look up
his image
this guy Brian Singer news he's a big
time Hollywood
uh bigwig and this man has parties with
like little kids and drugs it's just
horrific I mean he is like a known
Predator alleged known alleged in my
opinion 100 in my opinion yes well no
the reason I say that consent he has
nothing it's not my claim I saw it in a
movie yeah I got you in 1997 a 14 year
old extra accused singer of asking him
and other reminders to film a shower
scene nude
uh for the film apt pupil two other
adolescent boys 16 17 years old later
supported the 14 year old's claim
oof yeah I don't know how he's not in
jail but he so this is another weird
thing is that like people over the years
have all accused him or brought suits
against him and they all mysteriously
dropped them or was that Spacey I don't
know uh Spacey is the one where they
mysteriously kept dying
laughs
let's see sexual assault allegations 14
year old yeah that's one I just read uh
he was accused of essaying a minor
yada yada in 2014 another suit was filed
by an anonymous British man
who says he was uh essayed when you go
below 16 like 15 and stuff like that
that then you know by all means okay so
keemstar at least approves here it's not
that bad
I guess if there were 16 keemstars on
Brian's side
singer cited in the 2014 documentary
film a child this is the one I saw this
is in my opinion the Open Secret I saw
this this movie and I [__] and it tore
me up inside because
it's about this like manager
who's friendly with Brian and they all
had parties and stuff and he would find
like these child actors in kind of small
towns in the kind of like not the
greatest conditions who are like
desperate to make it and he would get
really close to the families and the
kids and work on their career and he
would um
molest them it was just horrific and bro
and they actually focused a lot on Brian
Singer and uh the stuff that he's been a
legend of doing
he is really gross man like really like
how did we get on this though we were
talking about the usual suspect we're
talking about Kenneth Copeland
and then you and I said ah [__] yeah I
remember we're so far off the trails
I'll get back there but actually I want
to see who because all these years I've
been like who is working with this guy
right well I think insane I think the
most recent allegations have uh stifled
his career because he was uh
fired from the two most recent movies
that he was working on from those
allegations and he hasn't done anything
since so it's just funny because those
allegations have been around for a while
like if I knew about it they sure [__]
knew about it right and Bohemian
Rhapsody 2008 18. 18 I learned about
that way before
and Legion I know about it way before I
was watching the show I liked it when I
found out he was directing it I said
[__] that I'm out of this [__] even 2016
I think I saw that documentary when that
documentary come out didn't it say 2015.
okay
that makes sense yeah
or 2014. so he did X-Men apocalypse
Legion Bohemian Rhapsody did all this
[__]
[__] crazy
yep anyway
moving on to uh what the [__] we were
talking about so Kenneth nobeland
is a demon
and people think she got in him in 2019
singer settled lawsuit for 150 000 that
claimed TR ordered a 17 year old boy
2019 he denied the allegations keemstar
what's your opinion if they're 17. 16 is
the age of consent
Okay so
okay it's not that bad right okay he was
17 right then then you know by all means
I can't I can't agree with you on that
one came
let's let's watch
sausage yeah
she walked over there and said
we are with Inside Edition
the man this man talks like a [__]
demon like how does anybody follow him
he's so successful and Rich
just lost man I'm lost hello Rita God
you mean to tell me I made Inside
Edition I mean hey this is one of my
wife's favorite programs well it used to
be I didn't lie
we just hadn't watched it in a long time
that's the iconic I used to love you
until you've talked about me you were
100 credible until you talked about me
you know what got her attention my
airplane
sounded like anything familiar to you
[Laughter]
he's like yeah you don't have an
airplane you broke ass [__] give me your
money
he moves and sounds like a demon he
looks like a little melted plastic doll
I feel like he does he's so waxy and
he's waxy it's not human yeah that man
boosts off when people aren't around
it's [__] nuts and his eyes are like
so Crystal Blue do you remember that
video of him where his hand literally
looked so wet
pull that up oh my god
oh I know what you're talking about yeah
I remember that
fear oh and he doesn't pay tax by the
way he's living in a seven million
dollar tax-free estate because
apparently we're not supposed to tax
churches
even though churches can donate that
money to action political action groups
explain that to me
he has a net worth of
760 million dude oh my God that means
God loves you that's his theory that's
what that means
he and he talked about my Jets
God gave me that jet God
oh my God
I had an opportunity
right there on Inside Edition
to talk about Abraham and his wealth
to talk about the the curse of poverty
at all and it just went out everywhere
because I own a big airplane
I love how he says that like it's like
the most normal defendable thing
and wasn't it that he
had multiple or had like he had to spot
an even bigger one he had like upgraded
it or he had his own airstrip on his
estate
his is on your strip
yeah this is a good um this is a good uh
comparison he looks like the villain who
put on the mask yeah Dorian Dorian
I uh you know horrible person but his
acting career is not that bad
uh that movie the rally he did oh god
with Eric Roberts yeah wait he was in a
movie yeah we talked about it remember
he he was like a a reformed gangster and
he was like trying to help the other
gang members uh nobody had his own like
weird self-produced right that's that's
what we're talking about yeah yeah
there's the rally and the rally la I
love that for him
but you know what I'm saying he's like
oh and they just criticized a little old
me for having a chad
it's like saying they caught me at a
nice dinner y'all been to a nice dinner
right
well in his defense though God did tell
him to buy that jet that's what he said
right yeah so God told me to touch that
little boy's penis
now who now is God wrong no sir
no Siri yeah yeah you probably will if
someone told me this guy is like us I
mean come on what's the chances he's not
a serial
child molester like
odds are more than 50 he is in my
opinion
like look at that face man that's just
in my opinion it's a fact in my opinion
now
my brother Copeland you you own a 45
million dollar airplane yeah but you
don't know what I paid for it I love
that that's the best defense ever oh you
don't even know how much you know what a
deal I got baby I got me a good deal I
only paid
I only paid 35 million for it
you fool
that's right God
the salesman I said God spoke to the
salesman and told him to give me a nice
30 discount oh yeah Lord help me Jesus
ah got you now
this man literally [__] putting this
Mr Burns it's like yeah look at this
[__] bro you are not serious excellent
excellent
for sure like who are you he's like yo
he's basically just emoting I am a demon
as loud as possible
nowhere near that yeah amen but it's the
same airplane
amen and Gloria designed a new interior
for it oh a refurbed
oh and now he's [__] He's hissing
like again he's telling listen to this
he's hissing
sunny boy
it's a Salazar Slytherin right there
like if you're a Christian that believes
in this kind of stuff how is it this man
he's doing this he's hissing all the
signs it's all fair literally I'm not
even religious and I think this man's a
demon
I don't even believe in demons but if
there's one on this Earth it's him I'm
the new interior for it
there's literally no reason for him to
hiss
oh
I'm [__] gobsmacked and people this
guy's worth almost a Bailey
and a lot of you partnered
put us in it
but she didn't know that
yeah I don't think that's material dude
she didn't know I got a fat discount
she didn't know
that I got a fat demon
that I got a fat kill them kill virgins
then I got a fat discount
sacrifice through the Young
like that's what he's saying basically
such a psycho dude
I love him though because he's just like
living proof of how far gone [__] is
so who wants to give me some
um
hahaha
sloppy toppy
who wants to slay Jesus
so who wants to give me money today
[Music]
my name is Kenneth Copeland and I was
born
to Lucifer himself Hallelujah I am the
Antichrist
I am assembling as many farms as I can
get to raise my Army of evil it's the
blood of God that's right that's right
I got me some rednecks out here with pit
force and guns the NRA cry when they see
the Arsenal my boys got
from Death to life it's coming the day
is coming the Antichrist shall strike
using the soldiers of God
ain't that a eight data poem
[Music]
[Laughter]
I got me this airplane I'm gonna fill it
with as much fuel as possible
uh-huh
fly it into a city a side scraper
[Music]
that's right
we're gonna March into the city
we're gonna blow up every Church in the
country
and then
we're gonna have a bunch of gay sex in
the street
and all the Jesus fear and people of the
world they won't know what hit him I'm
gonna suck a thousand dicks that evening
the Reckoning is Upon Us hours
[Music]
and when the Reckoning days come we
shall crowd the streets
and debauchery shall reign
[Music]
s
wow that is so demonic
we shall have Commit sodomy on the
floors of the Church of the Lord
everywhere
and we shall welcome the Jews with use
Open Arms the most demonic plan of Valor
we shall lock hands with the Jews and
make peace amen hallelujah
we will walk We will walk into poor
black neighborhoods and donate
to after school programs and Jesus will
cry
[Music]
uh here's here's here's his wet hand
actually what the [__] television said
yes Lord hallelujah thank you Jesus
wait does he have this Lord Jesus
that man's made of what he received he's
dripping he's melting he's a homunculus
bro
it's probably some uh sacred oils or
holy water I took some K-Y Jelly and
jerked off in the bathroom
take a vial of my Holy Spirit
stand against coronavirus I like how
it's like uh we stand against
coronavirus hey that's a stance we can
all get behind right we respect not
those liberals there what's
Coronavirus
I don't like it they're gonna stand
against him you know what you're asking
not based not not based not based
not based not based it is not the moment
your healing yes
lick my hand dear and be healed say it I
take it this man thinks he's a Jedi what
are you doing bro stop it stop being
silly you're a grown man
I have it I have it it's mine it's mine
I thank you and praise you for it I
thank you forgive if I have ought
against any
[Music]
and I praise you that I'm well and whole
I praise you that I'm well your hail
Satan I mean praise the Lord
[Music]
that's him
Satan I mean Jesus will be here soon are
you hoarding to the word of God
I'm Healed yes can I consider not my own
body yes yes Lord I consider not
symptoms in my body symptoms but only
that which God has promised yes only
that what the word has said yes sir and
by his stripes I was healed and by his
stripes I am healed now I am trying to
get healed I'm the heel and the devil's
trying to give me the flu the devil's
trying to give you a flu that's all the
devil's got [__] he's not that
intimidating
the devil's trying to spoil your milk
The Devil Is Coming For You
stuffing up my nose
got me a stuffy nose damn
I'll tell you what man today I went to
McDonald's and they forgot the cheese
devil
the devil don't it oh
[Music]
love him
what else we got we got all kinds of
coke so anyway I like that clip here's
another one of them or is under which
the Canadian office
uh is
it
don't you aren't you embarrassed don't
you feel silly oh God how dumb are you
I'm sorry but these people here are
[__] dumb man
maybe I'm being too close-minded or
something but you have a grown ass man
boy
the Lord is speaking through my mouth
and he says Google
God God's powerful words are coming
through my mouth Boogie Doogie boo-boo
booby poop booger Bop up
that's what God's telling you
death God is speaking through your mouth
and saying
booger Google
yeah that is what a stroke looks like
the movement of the spirit of God or is
under which the Canadians
[Music]
he's a Scatman that's funny
foreign
so that's um
that's our boy there for you Kenneth
noblin
like to [__] on him at any chance I get
it to be honest pull up a picture of his
estate there's pictures of it from the
air he's got his own airstrip and stuff
[Music]
time
scat with me now demon
dude
well I'm talking in tongue I didn't even
know
look at this this man he's so evil he
[__] killed the scenery around his
house it all died
before he moved in this was Lush and
beautiful and green
now it looks like a hellscape
for real why is his why is it like a
hellscape around his house I think it
was to help pave the road for the
private airport that he has right next
door
why he needed to kill all the greenery
around his house I think stuff just dies
around him
this he's like walks on the grass and
like the plants under his feet dot
wither and die you know
show me his uh airstrip
check this out right now God said I
shall play tennis amen
God said you shall have your own tennis
court Copeland
[Music]
[Laughter]
I want to see his airstrip that that
last photo I sent it has that
oh we needed like a satellite image yep
so here's his airstrip where's his house
which one's his house this one that's
down left corner it's like a little
island it looks like this is his church
like he owns this whole Peninsula yeah
yeah his ministry is right there that's
awesome good for you I like to be away
from the ministry don't not uh
unclean folks near my home
I wonder what's this is this where he
does the child sacrifice
you know I think that's further up
yes
yes yes
[Music]
anyway that's Kenneth nopeland everybody
you can donate to his church at um
I'm not I am not the antichrist.com
Andrew as we also reported does not have
cancer I don't know if we talked about
that was that pre-show
you said we're the only the only people
supporting
the news the only ones he says I do not
have cancer my lungs contain precisely
zero smoking damage in fact I have an
eight liter lung capacity I know because
I've been being waterboarded they told
me exactly how much water fits in my
lungs and the vital signs of an Olympic
Athlete there's nothing but a scar on my
lung from an old battle
true Warriors are scarred inside and out
[Music]
pointed toe is ridiculous
[Laughter]
point in that Towing what are you a
ballerina literally he did not have to
do that are you ready to do a little
twirl for us there uh Tate
so pretty feet you're so cute I love how
you twirl Andrew
play a play once for me how do you call
that when they do that play do a play
ons for me yay plie back to fifth can I
get a plie and back to fifth Andrew do
give us a twirl and rest
Andrew dates give us a twirl Lord
it's the finest ballerina who's ever
come to our school
[Music]
hmm
smoko and he can take a touch like
anyone I've ever met
oh that shit's funny what an idiot loser
dumbass I'm dreaming of my next Tucker
[Music]
Jimmy Lee was on Instagram live causing
absolute man I had nothing I just want
to say I had nothing to do with this in
fact he went live he didn't tell us and
I think one of y'all just caught the
live and started recording it right
that was Ian yeah
okay I have questions he posted this
picture
um he says fomo is contagious this is
what is happening here the Super Saiyan
Jimmy he's playing Dracula that's what's
happening here he's in Bram Stoker's
movie
like they have the same hair
his hair is actually incredible when you
consider that this is a painted odd
hairline like all of this like imagine
what it would look like without that it
would be crazy dude but the fluff is
like none other
is this photoshopped so we were we were
searching because we were we were
debating before the show it's not
because if you look at if you look at
other shots from that night which is on
his Instagram it's it's there it's very
consistent I have a I have a little bit
of a theory I think he's using the ultra
wide lens it's distorting it a little
bit a little bit on top there's some
pool
this I'm sorry these pictures are just
so funny for me
he love a good book I love me a good
pukaki in the morning Andrew Tate
nothing wake me up like the load of a
hundred men
all right Jimmy slay well he was in um a
restaurant
he had that one good bit in the
restaurant that we all liked and now he
can't give up on the idea
uh he's trying to get us to do film a
restaurant scene with him right Zach
yeah um so he frequents a place which he
he talks about publicly it's called
cipriani's in New York and
um it's a really upscale restaurant he
wants us to come fly to New York for
this [__] no no so there's another place
in La that someone owns that is a part
of cipriani's and he called me and he's
like I know the manager blah blah blah
and I'm like okay fine you know it's
cool good for you bud but imagine going
to this nice restaurant this [__]
[__] comes up to you when you're
trying to enjoy your meal with his
[__] uh cotton candy cotton Brown
whatever that's how you talk about your
uncle
I have one
well I don't have to imagine Zach I can
see it right here right right exactly my
Proctologist has brown fingernails
[Music]
wait a second to pulling us over here I
like watching from a distance because
I like the Ian's in the chat oh yeah
Ian said Doctor I've got a case of fomo
oh no this is the birthday girls okay
I'm gonna give an extreme cringe warning
this is [__] horrible he ruins this
girl's birthday
this is definitely extreme I love Ian's
commentary on it in the chat Jimmy
Neutron because of the hair oh no no I
was talking about in in this video Ian's
commenting yeah he's live he's telling
him to stop he's trying to get him he's
trying to tell him not to push
I like that and you said that because it
gives us plausible deniability smart man
yeah but you can't stop the push
it's like a big old dump you can't stop
the push
anyway extreme cringe warning I'm
telling you know
yay happy birthday
I don't think they're calling me James I
don't push
[Music]
happy birthday buddy you're a good man
what's your name
first name
he's doing all this for 50 people
watching
uh better it's better than three I don't
understand the phone situation I I can't
tell if he's on a call or he's recording
his audio I think oh audio audio of
course well why he's on a live
streaming I think he has a video camera
as well but also in other I think it was
the same day when he went to the other
restaurant he had a a lav mic on so ask
him text him he'll answer you oh he
definitely will
mm-hmm
[Music]
bro no shot look at that hair
wait hold on there's a I think it's just
talking to himself look at that hair
what else really look at it
what was that better how is that better
I think a full inch of black paint
Jimmy how is that better it's not better
wow wouldn't it be nice look at that
[__] hold on
[Laughter]
crazy so bad it's so bad
oh he just responded
uh no using for audio since it's loud
that's what I thought he's must have
recorded a video yeah he's recording a
video separately there got it yeah he's
got there's people behind me and see the
Magic in the making hey the outlaw
yeah he's not gonna I he's definitely
recording a video because he has that
hairline I don't think he would do all
that just for Instagram live
do that to him
that's not a paying gig someone just
painted black on your forehead like I
don't get it he also uh uses a product
to fill in the top it's like um
it's like a powder almost on the on the
keep up part yeah it's like a little sod
no on the lawn well that's that at least
is not I'm not noticing is that like the
hair hair in a can [__] yeah used to be
on infomercial yeah pretty much yo but
yeah the hairline I mean dude
this is unreal what he's walking around
like like that oh no one will notice
bro it's an inch of paint everybody's
noticing we need to get him a wig or
something hey I would like to do a hair
system for him yeah we could find we
could find the system that works for him
because I feel like he's still trying to
figure out one time he used a napkin the
entire call he just held it there oh
really
you like question him why aren't you
wearing your like where's your line and
he literally put up a brown napkin and
held it for the rest of the call didn't
talk about it he just kept it there
ask him if he would get a hair system
okay
pretty nice if Shalon just said Jimmy
Lee help yourself
but I didn't hear it yet
and listen get a room and tonight uh
Azure tonight when you're with the lady
she can be on the bottom
listen to me Ashley it's so
inappropriate
[Music]
dude she is like ready to scream like
help
so [__] like inappropriate pushed
almost gonna say he should be arrested
he gets bounced out of the restaurant
right
Legend says that his hairline recedes
with every bad joke says Hey Lord who is
a true she lore
I like their names the fan I think we
need more lore
see you later happy birthday
okay we are starting up at the Hard Rock
Cafe
I'm honestly shocked he didn't go in for
the ice cream because he's done that
before he almost did he was like hey why
aren't you offering me a bite he uh he
got kicked out right after this oh yeah
good yeah
yeah good yeah I think he needs to be
arrested to be honest
because
it's just not right what he's doing
going into restaurants like that like
there
he's gonna how has he not got his ass
beat too you would think oh the cameras
it's the cameras that's why and the
bodyguards that he rolls around with I
have right like X is really [__]
special forces
yeah one of the guys wanted to kill me
by the way speaking of lore our first
lore videos going up this Saturday
very exciting very exciting
so there's fomo activity out there in uh
it was so much fun little activity out
there and uh well Hard Rock Cafe is that
Vegas or did they have they have those
other other elsewhere they're all
different flavors all different flavors
the Hard Rock okay
um so I got an update from a few minutes
ago that they are almost to Walmart so
should be ready in uh just a few minutes
here oh how we went on Bert Chrysler
show and was talking about us a brand
new March what is the brand new March
dude Howie is like an H3 missionary at
this point like he is the [__] man
I love him so much let's see what the
brand new merch is
it's just a black this is nine minutes
though to be no just the first just the
first minute
stuff it's a lot of things with stuff
that the first one look go back to the
first one that said is this covet
related is do you know what that is no
so I I did a uh a post on Tick Tock that
got me in trouble it was a prolapsed
anus do you know what a prolapse anus is
Rachel just brought this up she just
brought she goes did anyone see how
these posts on the prolapse than us I
definitely know what a prolapse anus is
why you say that was such pride no I
know I just follow a lot of porn stars
and I've heard their struggles wait is
that a struggle because I I did you know
what H3 is the podcast h3a3 yeah yeah so
and so he he's incline yeah he he
celebrated it and he had a guy on that
does a prolapsed anus trick for uh he's
got a he's got a like a a website where
he does it on for porn he can actually
prolapse his anus I think I know this
it's like uh you know how you know this
guy I think I met this guy I think he
was backstage at my show in in Vegas
backstage yeah okay backstage so but he
he can inflate and and protract his anus
and then suck it back in it's like
balloon animals for adults it's like an
elephant tough nose that's funny but you
can put a pencil and then elephant knows
his anus out grab it and then suck it
back up yeah I think he can so I don't
know if that's listen I'm a judge of
talent so pull up the prologue Santa's
picture I see it no oh my God are you
serious is that Ed is there more no they
just he watches the video and birds kind
of grossed out they don't show it
he watches the video no the the original
it's just a picture or the picture right
uh we can edit it out but I would like
to see it but I got in trouble for it
Howie Mandel prolapse Thanos that's not
what you want to be known for on the
internet enough that I do have so I
didn't know as a prolapsed anus I didn't
know what I was such a liar how he
stopped it I love you but stop lying
somebody said he said Ethan knows the
internet before it knows itself
that's nice
I don't know who said that but I love it
someone said how he's really dying on
that it was a wet cake Hill
yeah he's about to say it there yeah he
can never come out he can never come out
and admit did you guys see Brittany
Broski talk about it on tinymike I
didn't really watch it on the show
I don't think we watch on the show I
think we just it was set in the chat at
some point I don't think we oh it was
really funny uh Brittany was telling
them about the prolapse video I showed
her
funny man I love it
it's kind of a vibe that we have you
know
yeah I love the vibe right now we're
known as the uh the prolapse podcast now
and so where is uh do we have any
updates on on
um they're pulling into the parking lot
right now maybe he can start the feed
I'd like to check in with them I'd like
to see the whole shirt taking off
process and everything you know
that's the most [__] up thing that's
all important to me
here's Brittany talking about us it's so
funny I love this [__] what's the
nastiest thing you've seen on the
internet hi Reese recently went on
[__] H3 and Ethan showed me a video
of two prolapsed [__] rubbing
against each other
I'm kidding I'm kidding pull it up I'm
kidding it's not easy to pull up guys
you got to know somebody you gotta know
the record they get that one they need a
deal I mean it was like I haven't felt
that jarring like holy [__] why didn't
he show you that hey that's a great
question
no there is a backstory you know Howie
Mandel's Tick Tock how he's the [__]
man oh my God the the
uh Ripples and culture
from that prolapse are just incredible
man the butterflies act really is I saw
another clip of her on that podcast
where she said that we use AI for our
thumbnails I think she mistaked that way
because Cameron is so quick he's like a
machine
she really thinks that yeah oh that's
what I saw from them yeah it's a
compliment to cam Jimmy said he would
not get a hair system
so he prefers just to paint on his
forehead he said my hair is fine and
then at first I had to ask him three
times the same question because he said
call me call me call me I can't today
we're jam-packed I don't know you want
to call him we're waiting not really
yeah
um I mean it's up to you but it's it
always turns into a whole thing
um what is this Ian oh this is the hair
system yeah dude the Hair Systems out
today are incredible like check this out
uh mute it please
yeah I've actually seen a lot of videos
like this and I'm like maybe I'll just
shave it all off and go for this because
their hair looks hella good
so you said it's my hair is fine I just
pump it up when I do my comedy dude she
gotta shave that closer like what
Tony's bristles there
I want to know what kind of glue they
use because that should stay on for like
weeks
you see that what if stud man
crazy
what a stud it looks great doesn't it
different flavors all different flavors
yeah dude he looks like it's such a big
difference to be honest here he kind of
looks like a lonely [__] truck driver
or something or like I don't know and
then here he's like kind of a stud
do we agree
a studly truck driver he looks handsome
as [__] that's crazy transformation
[__]
all right can we get a can we are we
waiting for um
just waiting for the dialing should be
any minute now do they know to call in
just like yeah I said I told him to call
in as they enter okay
love the warhorn please sir
[Music]
yep
let him know we're coming let the horn
ring loud and far
we got a new Wendy Williams clip no way
dude she just keeps giving
she's given us enough man
she's giving us our privacy but please I
don't respect people's privacy that's
why I do the Hot Topic
but please I don't respect people's
privacy that's why I do the Hot Topic
oh an incredibly Lucid moment for her
that's that's actually great he's also
died
we all the top comment is unpopular
opinion I Miss Wendy Williams I we all
do
we all do
it's not just you I would ask you to
respect our privacy but please I don't
respect people's privacy that's why I do
the Hot Topic
sassy
keeping it real I love that okay it's
okay it's okay she's keeping it real man
wait Oliver tree went against the family
again it said Amy's gonna lose
why do we obviously I really care what
he thinks what he's on Dad's Channel
yep what the [__] say this with respect
um when Dad goes against AB it's gonna
be a bloodbath AB is down in the first
round I'm gonna give maybe three to five
seconds I don't know what was the last
guy you fought uh Matt Watson yeah when
Joe Rogan said that Matt Watson got beat
up by his dad he wasn't kidding dad took
him down and it was within what 30
seconds 22 seconds exactly and navy is
going down in under 10.
oh yeah yeah he doesn't know what he's
talking about yeah he doesn't like the
joke he is why don't you just go ask
random people on the street and be like
yeah you heard it here it doesn't mean
anything dude dad is going down faster
than your career Oliver
wow how do you like that
he's falling off since he had those kind
of tick tock tips
Nick Clark thank you so much I would
love to see super mega or TMG on the Pod
that'd be great me too Nick
let's look into that
um
you're coming up man I'm excited the
fight is coming up six weeks you feeling
good sweet yes yeah
did a hike on
Saturday which uh
was hell but uh I feel like it really
helped and his coach was really nice and
Alex Wassabi
really
how'd they perform are they like super
fit uh yeah yeah they they did good I
was uh behind them a little bit but I
was surprised I was able to finish that
was my first time so
what do you mean you went on a hike you
were running yeah we're running uh at
Griffith Park five miles in total oh
[__] that sounds pretty gnarly yeah
yeah so he went with X Alex Wasabi who's
idubbbz opponent and you went with
right your previous opponent yeah yeah
and uh his coach
got that kind of endurance
oh yeah no Brett was he was leading the
way yeah he looked he looked great whoa
that's where I messed up I was trying to
keep up with him at first and then Alex
Wasabi was telling me like don't just
don't don't try to keep up with him
because he's okay
exciting stuff
quite a community there and uh yeah the
boxing world all right I gotta get that
feed going I need to see shirtlessetti
out there
is asked ETA
I'm dying
they got all the stuff
[Music]
I need eyes on the battlefield
I can't stand this fog of War anymore
I need to see
with God's eye satellite vision
infrared we'll see who cancels who
that's right
well gamorulus
[Music]
broke the platform subscription record I
don't really care about that at all to
be honest
twitch [__] at all president Trump if
you see this please save us
child influencers are getting legal
protection that's good
oh yeah
let's go Amy
what's the significance of what you just
wrote
can I read that I don't want to I think
it's no I don't think you should I'm
trying to I'm just I know what you're
trying to say it's funny though I find
it very funny okay
I'm telling you the significance yeah
yeah yeah yeah go ahead you can read it
no I know the significance yeah I can
read it yeah go ahead Amy Says
it was during Black History Month and he
was a black Creator who broke the record
there you have it Kai chanette is the
star of Black History Month
I think it's a big deal
I am black
I mean yeah
it's cool
Black History Month we honor you
twitch.tv honors you
yeah
okay but a month we gotta we gotta lower
that down to like a minute at most
just kidding that's not my joke that's
Jordan Peterson's joke really a month
really a month what happened Pride used
to be a sin and month that's a little
ear pushing it you're pushing it there
bucko
Black History Month you're pushing it
where's White History Month
um
uh Kate Kaylee said just started Lexapro
Ethan thanks for always being so open
about your mental health Journey it
helped me so much God bless you thank
you I'm glad
I'm glad
that shit's great it's gonna do good for
you
guys accept so um
oh
we gotta feed I've got Cameron in the
lobby oh God
[Music]
this is big this is big folks
can you hear me Kim yes I can hear you
okay all right great so let's look at
the state of the display can you back it
up oh it's in disarray look at this oh
everything looks kind of disarray this
is a shame here
this is actually really something I mean
this this all the other ones look good
and the Mr Beast one is completely
mammed somebody terrorized this whole
aisle I've got to fix this so you think
please get on it Eddie dude that service
Eddie is now being put to work on behalf
of Mr Beast
Jimmy or Eddie Eddie is a good man
shirtlessetti is there beautifying Mr
Beast chocolate aisle we are doing this
for the team yo bro don't drop them
careful careful be careful
Precious Cargo
this is precious cargo these are very
very nice chocolates and we've got to
make sure that these are put in here
properly absolutely yeah get the you
can't let it flip down like that
I think that that one is overstuffed
maybe Eddie the purple one yeah just
take yeah yeah yeah that's good yeah
oh see this and this is what it's this
is what Jimmy's talking about if you
find yourself in Walmart
just do like Eddie's doing
pretend you're a [__]
shelf
better there it is make sure you get
that one cosplay you worked there
over here very good
right so that it looks a lot better okay
wow
Eddie wow now wow look at that that is
so much nicer and then they have to be
all from Center and standing straight up
like they are just a military uh The
Beautiful Beast Mode Mr Beast right here
now Eddie
Eddie uh there was an implication from
Jimmy that you should mess up the
Hershey display
oh really yeah I love you well
let's just messed up the Hershey looks
like oh nice that looks ugly as hell now
yeah that's what I'm saying nobody's
buying that oh but he's buying match
hey we'd improve our loyalty to you Mr
Beast
oh many podcasts are proving their felty
to Mr Beast like we are
how many how many podcasts specifically
well that's it very little he's an
official representative
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking about
wow let me get a good shot of that Mr
Beast row there
that's excellent work Jimmy that is
fantastic all different flavors
Mr Beast is front and center now they
were out here
we came all nicely right here on the
shelf for Mr Beast Festival wow
fantastic all different flavors well
thank you for doing that service you're
you did a fantastic service there's
another Walmart where
electricals we bless you bless them yes
yes yes
Eddie Shirley said he will you read the
ingredients of one of those
I sure will yeah this is what the
ingredients are right here Mr Beast
first of all ingredients are let's see
ingredients are the wonderful cane sugar
organic chocolate liquor and they have
the organic cocoa butter okay sunflower
oh yes
oh yes and the uh information is may
contain peanuts and it has uh nuts and
milk and soy and okay and how many
calories is in that bar oh yes and the
calories are 170 calories oh that's not
for the whole bar 170 that's great yeah
that's not bad that's fantastic
can we
can we pitch it is anyone walking by you
guys can you try to sell one of those
yeah would you like to buy a Mr Bean
it's public
sea salt so there's only 170 calories
there five ingredients and they're very
very nutritious and delicious and look
how delicious
see how it tastes look how bad it has
you can get prizes and
you'll really love him would you like to
buy one
yes
wow
[Applause]
another podcast who's actively putting
those bars in carts
wow oh he's going he's good doing it
he's getting things done
that's my man
Eddie you're incredible wow incredible
sales fantastic job show this to Mr
Beast oh he'll see it we are promoting
your product right here Mr B's
properties
oh ela's watching she just dropped her
big LOL in the chat we're being we're
being spotted right now okay so Eddie
let's wrap it up I think your work there
is done let's go head to the next
Walmart and let's keep we got to push
the front line you know what I mean push
the front line push the front
thank you Eddie you are amazing that was
incredible
yeah you could yeah okay so we'll see
you in a little bit thank you buddy all
right thank you Eddie you're the man
love you we're on to the next one
dude
oh yeah he got it all right we'll see
you guys soon all right see you soon all
right he had his shirt on the bread
aisle
love Eddie what did he Crush that he
just sold I don't think he's fixing he
sold two bars and he was two for two in
sales that's 100
that was okay so they're going to the
next Walmart
it's about
15 minutes away
and we'll check on that aisle
and do our due diligence do our our dues
to Mr Beast
who
frankly doesn't deserve to have his
display disheveled
he doesn't deserve it after all he's
done for us
wow
he's the best he's the best I love him
I hope they get out there safely though
yeah so Dan can you communicate to cam
that in 15 minutes when they arrive at
the next one we'll we'll check it again
sure can do yeah
that was awesome
I think that'd make a good highlight
love
definitely clip shirtless Eddie dude
tag Mr Beast for sure too mm-hmm
well if they do get kicked out just make
sure we get we can capture the moment
and think
that's important to me uh cam just let
me know that uh Eddie uh is doing a
shirtless video with someone real quick
wait I want to see I want to see I want
to see that
he's doing shirtless videos I mean maybe
he may be a fan a fan spotted him he's
always on that grind dude I gotta see I
want to know how the sausage is made on
those
I love that he's there and he's like
he's he's making the best of it
oh well cam says he's looking for
someone yeah he uh before the show he
wants to get some some some videos in
while he's there pull it up Cam he's
doubling up yeah I want to watch that I
just told him to call back when uh
they're gonna do it here here just send
this to Mr Beast before
after that is fine
please get this please get this in front
of him I want all the and
yeah it's fantastic wow what a service
what an honor
you know only those ones were messed up
it does make me wonder if people were
going out of their way to mess it up
you know I wonder that too
who could have done that
also if you guys can tweet at him that
we're literally selling bars too I mean
uh yeah that's the best he's got plenty
of foot soldiers out there defending but
how many salesmen
oh [__]
that is so awesome yeah well definitely
gotta tag him I wanted to get as many
followers as we can uh love hook them up
with tag everywhere we post them I'll
tag him everywhere yeah thank you
non-stop thank you
yes so
well as we wait for them to call back in
we have some great news child
influencers are getting some legal
protection this is very good news
man we've been talking about this for a
long time yeah the US is finally dealing
with the exploitation of child
influencers
okay
not her
she's one of the good ones she's a queen
yeah yeah
Washington State specifically
has proposed a bill called the child
protection from exploitation act aimed
at protecting child influencers from
exploitation the bill would require
platforms like YouTube Tick Tock and
Instagram to provide more transparency
around their policy for childhood
influencers and their partnership with
Brands would also prohibit platforms
from collecting or using personal
information for child influencers
without their consent
and their parents I think they already
did that with the
they got busted recently for like
violating some child Privacy Law
a few years ago the bill would also give
influence child influencers the right to
request that their content be deleted
from the platform once they reach the
age of maturity
even if they previously consented to its
use that's very good that's a very uh
good little line they inserted there
that's so good they keep they're giving
all the power to the kids right when
they become an adult right and that's
how that's what it should be
they also performed extensive research
from the Coogan law which was passed in
1939 to protect child actors in
Hollywood from exploitation to establish
the best methods to protect a child's
income from their parents right let's
[__] go yeah this really is
everything you guys have been talking
about for a while
this is this is great yeah like in the
Coogan law which only applies to a
handful of states the drawback of
establishing regulations on estate
levels that children access
across the rest of the United States
won't be offered the same protection of
those living Washington yeah but it's a
start
you know
the risk is that parents of child
influencers in Washington could move out
of state if they felt their income was
being threatened yeah it's it's but it
could help start creating sort of a
template for these types of laws and
then that's how it oftentimes happens a
bunch of states will
pick up that legislation and pass it in
their own states exactly it's the first
one you know it's an archetype McCart
McCarty
has had interest from other states
regarding house bill this house bill but
has decided to concentrate on getting
legislation passed in Washington for now
in the future I'd love to see some
federal recognition they said adding
that this could be
a form of an unless
so has he found so has he has he got any
luck yet cam
still running gun out here okay
why is he putting back on his shirt
it didn't work out huh
[Music]
more security cameras than on
so we're gonna go to a different Walmart
in 10 minutes we could be there yeah
they won't know you there yeah sounds
good did you tell me you were putting
did you tell them you're putting items
in people's cart I mean you're
generating money yeah you're doing sales
yeah because we are generating sales oh
wow that's a shame
probably just uh you know freaked out
because of the fact that they thought
that maybe we were messing up their
shelves or something why couldn't it be
further from quite the opposite in fact
it was totally the opposite did you were
you able to film a shirtless Eddie uh
video yeah I did two of them yeah two of
them it's still running gun
are they up already or how does that
work are you you edit it later okay
we're getting kicked out
are those videos up now or um do you
have to edit them I'm just on a call
right now
well it's on a it's a call
it is a call that's not a lie yeah okay
yeah it's a it's a video call is that
okay no recording okay
well we'll talk to you soon we'll talk
to you later
all right thank you guys we're heading
out all right thank you guys yeah it's a
life goal but yeah all right he's Daniel
he didn't tell a lie that's exactly
right he's on the phone call
those soldiers man
It Ain't Easy Being a soldier you know
they're on a couple of risks you know
they're taking greens they call it the
greatest sacrifice they're in the
trenches they're taking grenades they're
taking mortified mortar fire and all in
the name of protecting those chocolate
bars
nothing is more pertinent or important
to society today
[Music]
they can kick us out
but they cannot change our objective we
are
they can ask us to leave but we will
always be back we are
they may tell us to put on our shirts
but we will always
remove them we are
wait did he already post this yeah he
posted it and at the very very end you
could kind of see him look off to the
side like they're about to get kicked
out wow he already posted it that's
incredible
let's see
hey Eddie what are you doing at Walmart
with your shirt off come on man
hey I'm Eddie I love being try to listen
to Walmart that's what I do I love being
shirtless I'm Eddie so I could do that
I'm an idiot
dude
you know there's something kind of
heartwarming about his content and that
just how welcoming and P and okay people
are to help him shoot these videos
it's kind of a beautiful thing isn't it
magical was this the other one
I think this is from today too isn't it
yeah four minutes ago way over here in
Walmart with no shirt on put your shirt
back on
yes I'm here in shirtless in a Walmart
because I'm Eddie I can do that I can be
sure listen to Walmart with my shirt off
I'm here at Walmart I love being
shirtless hey I'm Eddie and I'm Walmart
with my shirt he is perfect he is he is
an angel
good moment
lovely
I'm glad he's able to make content out
of it you know it's a it's a double
whammy yeah it's a win-win he asked cam
to do another one today and I I had to
interject myself because I've become
such a fan
um so you're in a shirtless anyway I'm
gonna share this any video yeah is that
posted is it up yeah wait does this sit
with you and cam yeah yeah okay
hey Eddie welcome back to the H3 podcast
it's me Cameron we're happy to have you
here exact the sound light Here Eddie we
love you we always do you're allowed to
have your shirt off here in fact we
encourage you having to encourage it we
want to see your cheat cheese we want to
see everything thank you for bringing
the chichis thank you for taking your
shirt there we go it's gone it's gone my
element at the H3 podcast Studios and
look I can have my shirt off here the
guys are cool with it I'm Eddie and I
love having my shirt off hey we're gonna
have a lot of fun today so tune in at
one o'clock Pacific time for the H3
podcast and anytime that you want to see
it you can always watch it on YouTube
and I am right here at the H3 podcast
can you believe it I'm Eddie and I love
being here we love you Eddie yeah we're
trying to get him to a hundred thousand
by the way he's at
9 79 000 so he's getting close
um
golly hey what a guy
oh did we so we're tweeted and by the
way guys please show some support on
Twitter we gotta get Mr Beast Mr Beast
needs to see this uh we're cleaning the
feasible shelves One Mall bird at a time
one down five to go guys please before
after now come on
can we get one of him putting the
chocolate bar in that girl's car as well
please
you know
can I like my own tweet and retweet it
maybe I can this is annoying to retweet
your own tweet so you see it twice in
the timeline yeah
yeah guys can we please uh Soldier up
this war is active this is a hot War
thank you
there it is
all right so as we move on to the next
Walmart
um
we'll continue on
uh but one sec
where we're strategizing for our next
plan of attack it's not that easy you
need War plans
you know we need to consult with our
generals
all right I'll just break it to you guys
there's only one Walmart in La no
there's not
[Music]
are they gonna are they gonna drive
there yeah okay
I thought there was a problem you said
there was a problem well I'll just I'll
just break it to you guys then we were
gonna pretend like there was five
different Walmarts in La I mean people
would have noticed because the Shelf
looks the same but they got kicked out
so we can't do that but now they're
actually driving to another one 17
minutes away
kick
so they are go aheaded to a different
Walmart not even a [__] sketch
anymore
[Applause]
that's what the [__] I'm talking about
yeah but back to so the kids so we love
the kids we protect the kids
[Music]
we protect the kids like we protect
feastable cars we love okay let's folks
we love them and I've Loved kids jumping
on my lap we love the kids jumping on my
lap
um
I'm surprised they were able to go for
so long without getting kicked out that
was a good long like 20 30 minutes maybe
even in there
so congratulations
um I have been wanting to talk about
this story for a minute musk loyalists
who slept in the office was fired and
recent layoffs this picture was actually
somewhat viral
that's just kind of how like
people were so eager to prove their
Worth to Elon
and there was a picture of this girl
this woman sleeping on the floor
when you need something from your boss
at Elon Twitter
this um
was posted not as a joke right this was
posted as a real
like trying to Big Ups her I think this
was Esther Esther Crawford
yeah it was my understanding it was
serious
okay so she quote tweeted and said when
your team is pushing around the clock to
make deadlines sometimes you sleep where
you work
and again it's like
I get there proud and that they're doing
good jobs and they're working for Elon
but like this is not
this is not the future that I want
I do not want I do not dream of a future
where people are sleeping at on the
floor of their job so they can wake up
and have more time to work
uh so this picture went kind of viral
and what's funny is even her proving her
loyalty to Elon
she's still got laid off
um Esther Crawford the head of Twitter
payments that sounds like an important
job was fired
Twitter laid off at least 50 employees
Saturday night including Crawford and
Elon Musk loyalists who had withstood
the company's Rocky transition
he's just a cold blooded capitalist
you know and at the end of the day he
just doesn't give a [__] about you at
all like he's using you look at you
you're you've wasting your finite time
on this Earth
neglecting and any other
piece of life that you have for Elon
Musk who is worth a gajillion dollars
and actually doesn't [__] care about
you at all
discarded you like a used tampon
sorry about that
[Music]
he's based
I guess yeah he is based
and so
um
yeah even after being let go she's still
proud of her work at the company golly
I mean this is what being cucked is
right
here she is talking about her
uh wonderful time she says the worst
take you could have from watching me go
all in on Twitter 2.0 is that my
optimism or hard work was a mistake it's
not your fault
like I get you're trying to do a good
job but it's just it's not my fault
you're just being used you're just being
used and abused you didn't do anything
wrong it's good to care about your job
and to work hard
those who jeer and mock are necessarily
on the sidelines and not in the arena I
mean if you're in the office job chill
out it's not like you're at a desk job
you're in a sleeping bag on the floor
yeah come on you're not creating art
here there's no Arena
I'm deeply proud of the team for
building through so much noise and chaos
yeah she she's proud of her team and
that's all good I just think that you
know this isn't the kind of culture that
we should be working towards top
response is pretty good
you're getting mocked because you tried
to normalize toxic leadership and work
culture in service of a billionaire who
fired 90 of your company and then ended
up getting fired the very thing you were
defending it's pretty funny
I mean that's well put for sure I don't
I don't blame her for normalizing it
though because like if that if she cares
about her job and she thinks that's what
she needs to do to keep her job then
it's really the workplace's fault
I really see her as a victim right of
capitalism
of the of Elon Musk so but I mean it is
well said right is very well said there
I just think it's uh more of like her
doing that when so many people are
losing their jobs like it's a little
callous yeah yeah it's a little callous
it is weird that she's so proud of it I
think why she did that is because she
wanted Elon to notice her but she was
trying to be a baby mama
she was trying to be the 11th baby mama
she wanted a horse
I want some of that butter cup semen
but uh I'm sure she'll uh be fined you
know she's she's got some good
experience there sleeping in X product
Twitter yeah you can
you can remove that
previously CEO
fired by Twitter in 2020 which was
acquired by Elon Musk 2022. dude you
have three kids okay that's a problem
for me
I was assuming she was single when I saw
her sleeping on the floor
but she has three kids dude that's
that's
really hard
she's married to Bob Cowherd
Bob coward
uh Prada he's also a digital dude exuber
and Amazon why do people post their
their jobs they got fired from
I used to work at UH Uber and Amazon
hmm
they tag each other oh God these people
are doomed
as someone with two kids man missing a
knight like a whole night is is intense
it's intense
that's a little dark
you know it's like what I got 20 kids
and I never see any of them
what's the problem
you have Sunday to see them
oh I wanted to tell you guys we got some
news on the um IVF we're doing
so Ela had 31 he had 31 eggs extracted
yeah
I know it's crazy it's it is crazy
but then um come on fertile Queen she is
yeah and then so then the next day they
told us they called they ins they
fertilized them the next day and then
they tell us how many are
successfully fertilized so of the ones
that were successfully fertilized it
would think it was 17.
whoa and there's three that might that
might still be viable
and so
now they're gonna like grow them a
little bit
and then they can do like
it's crazy they can screen the embryos
for any kind of genetic anomalies
and they can also tell us which one is a
boy and which one's a girl
and they and they also know the quality
right so like you're you're gonna wait
for the highest quality ones that you're
you're I think the higher the quality
the less likely high value male yeah
maybe exactly and so um
the goal is to end up with like three
high quality viable embryos
and that hopefully you get the choice
between a boy and a girl
I told Eli work cursed I'm kidding it's
not a curse I love my boys but just the
joke that I keep telling her is that
we'll we'll only ever have boys
but we'll see like our our uh the doctor
there with the fertility doctor she's
has four kids she did IVF twice and she
has four boys she's like it's all she
got in the end when she did the egg
extracts and stuff she only ended up
with boys
it's funny
I just it's just a joke I tell you that
she's gonna end up with she's the she's
surrounded by men I mean two boys dad
two male dogs right she's praying she
needs she needs a Ally
yeah science is crazy isn't it
I also did this genetic screening I'm
waiting for the results it's this new
thing Ila did it it screams you for 500
rare genetic disorders to see if you're
a carrier
and now they're testing me on the same
ones to see if we both have the same
recessive
carrier
500.
and then if the if they find out that we
have the same recessive
Gene for a for these uh diseases they
can go test the embryos to see
if the embryo has that disease
is that [__] crazy
it's indeed
so there that is huh
[Music]
my darling here
I always think it's funny when singers
go
[Music]
Celine
Dolly Parton oh I didn't know that but
he became
[Music]
oh he
didn't quite go for it there
[Music]
oh there you go
can I ask you guys a question about that
song do you guys hear it a lot at
American weddings like Arabs think
that's like a love song I think and I
hear it at every wedding as like a first
dance song and it's this I don't think
I've heard it once yeah I just think
about The Bodyguard which is such a sad
movie which is where it's from right I'm
not the families
yes it is oh okay
hmm I think about Titanic for some
reason but I don't think that was no
that's Celine Dion That's My Heart Will
Go On but she's saying that one too
right yeah no no no no no oh it's not
I'd never I don't think I've heard that
song in like 20 years to be honest with
you would you like to hear a Nook sing
it right yeah I know it sings it well I
mean I listen yes of course uh
everything a Nook does is
urgent
I don't know if Zach had a chance to
take the background sound yeah we just
found that one yeah speaking of a Nook
I've over the weekend went back and
watched the winners video like 10 times
probably
because I love that song so much I want
to pull it up it was just
so fantastic I got it we were bumping it
this morning as well
bees from space
check it out
[Music]
oh this is such a hit
[Applause]
[Music]
we got subtitles let's see if they can
figure out what he's saying
you know
hey everyone that's right in other words
[Music]
[Applause]
so I also noticed the little figure of
me is made of Legos yeah we didn't catch
that for real yeah so if you keep it
going keep it going it shows up again
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
that picture is so fun again
oh my hands
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
we got and we had the contact with uh
with our boy yet not yet
I wonder if he saw that he won this
whole damn thing I mean
I had that thought like if he
well if he saw this
without let it become a big before
talking to us he's so confused well
whoever you are I'd love to rip a
[__] guitar solo for you because you
[__] are dope as [__] dude you old
Zach collab with him would be pretty
yeah wait with the you're done no no I'm
talking about the bees for uh oh yeah
I'm in contact with him yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh I'm sorry I thought that's how
you were talking yeah no we're talking
about that nuke Oh I thought you want to
collab with the Nook well that'd be cool
too
all three of you yeah there you go bees
in space Zach is open for a
collaboration loved her episode for you
Ripa Dart rip a solo all happening yeah
guys
um it's just from I have never
just saying guys we have long days here
and I'd appreciate it if y'all didn't
clock out like so early like 10 p.m is
too early yo I'll get the sleeping bags
I'll get the sleeping mats I just said
you're asking us yeah yes I just expect
you guys to work a little longer that's
it if you want to keep the job
not saying I'd fire you but right well
you want to keep your job you need to
sleep here well then that sounds like
you you are saying that you're farther
fire no no that'd totally be me I'm the
one that would tweet the photo like I
love my job and then we want to get
fired and still defend Ethan yeah that
sounds about right
that's that's fun what a dummy so bad
for her she has kids man
where's Mommy oh her baby's learning to
walk
where's Mommy
I miss mommy she's sleeping on the floor
for [__] Elon Musk
is Mommy putting me to bed tonight no
sweetheart she has to work
crash cut to this
foreign
that's your life this is your life you
get only one life
this is it true
do not miss your shot
right
life was like a box of chocolates poor
scump knows that there's only one life
one love one God these glasses have
changed my life
mommy where's Mommy
I haven't seen mommy in three days
that's that's like verbatim to an intro
for an Alice Cooper song really yeah
is Mommy okay
[Music]
I want to show mommy my drawings
I want Mommy to make me dinner she's
such a good cook the mommy makeout day
crash cut
Elon Musk
is playing Elden ring
and has his feet up and micro dosing
laughing and giggling
and then another crash cut she's
sleeping on the floor
crash cut the Elon Musk again
I can't wait to fire her
I'm gonna lay her right off yeah
meanwhile he's posting [__] like this
yeah exactly
they look so cute and cuddly but the
slightest thing can turn this beautiful
creature into something so dangerous and
violent that the toughest of men could
be killed or man for it it's the joke is
so obvious it's not funny it's like so
stupid I mean come on dude 400 000 likes
but who are your followers like like
eight-year-olds I mean seriously
it's the opposite it's all like
seven-year-olds I guess Boomers might
find that for me
crazy
like I can't get over the fact that
people are simping for uh the richest
man in the world like like
this man exploits people for fun oh
actually I saw something
I gotta show you something actually I
saw a reply because you know there was
um
some issues with the website today uh it
was down this morning for a lot of
people quick update they pulled into the
parking lot of new Walmart okay that was
fast that was fast very good
they're gonna drive all the way to Vegas
hitting Walmart after Walmart
oh we got a chat Hanks update I saw this
is good yeah
I bought the lambo
they said my dad bought it for me
I almost get in a fight with a bum at
IHOP and they say I staged it
it's like I could come up with a cure
for cancer tomorrow
and they'll just say I only did it
because of my dad but you know I've been
dealing with my whole life but you know
the way I've learned to deal with this
frustration is to just you know light
some Sage
meditate Journal go for a walk you know
take a deep breath in
and just be at peace
Go sucker your mama duck his sticking
it put your granny Griff
there's like two chests there's like the
funny chat the light-hearted awesome
chat and then there's like down bad like
[__] giving and getting into fights
in IHOP exactly like down bad chat I
need to pull that that psych was
grave
crotch that video got me good I was
feeling bad for him in the beginning I'm
like yeah it must be hard to be in his
dad's Shadow all the time and then he
[__] got me right he got me too I
didn't expect it I was like dude cure
cancer I was like calm down bro
but then this was all cheeky
he's a good actor man he he is a good
actor maybe he does take after Tom Hanks
he dies he's a good one he's a showman
he takes after a forest he's more
villainous he's got Tom is like the
wholesome Hero has Tom ever played a bad
guy ever he is he played the colonel
yeah
what is that in the Elvis movie he
played the colonel [__] face for real
yeah
okay
yeah I actually think Chet's a good
actor he's got his Lamborghini hoodie on
bro you're come on stop
stop it
yeah so uh what was your pulling up for
me uh Dan divided it was just a stupid
like Elon sent meme that was very cringe
but oh I forgot yeah he did Chet
we offered for him to come on the show
he agreed if I would
pay for his 2500 workout plan
it's a shame should have done it
he's in great shape that would be a good
do it I'll be honest that would be a
powerful bit getting getting jacked with
Chet Hanks kind of a good deal 2500 for
tip for that bet I mean not bad
foreign
I'm not sure about how that go though
I'll surprise he even said that because
I thought he hated your guts yeah
I'll tell him I'll do it but you have to
only speak in Jamaican accent
I don't think that would be a problem
for him he's a very much enjoy it can
you ask cam to like start it
from when they are on scene because last
time you started at the aisle I like to
see the whole journey the whole
Adventure I you know every step every
step you take I want to be watching
oh can't you see
every step you take
um yeah I'm getting them on the line
right now
so just stand by a minute
hi having her big news
yeah I think he might just be trying to
fight me people are saying
he just wants to get me in the same way
what is this somebody in the chat just
dropped a little tidbit
Jeff has a barbershop episode that he
won't air with Chet he said they
threatened to sue what
should you find a clip of him talk oh I
want to ask Jeff about it ask him
should I text him or should I maybe I'll
call him
let's see if he'll answer Me Maybe text
him first and say I'm on the show can I
call you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
don't spring it on him okay
can I call to ask you about somebody
said Matt Wells Matt Watson did the Chet
Hanks workout and he lost to Dad ooh
yeah did he really
I don't know if he did I mean it could
have been a bit those Mega awesome guys
are weirdos
Mega awesome yeah Mega awesome that's
our mod
you're like
you're not getting enough sleep last
night or something no I slept good Ethan
what time you called you called Eddie
Jimmy like 10 times and you there was
another name mix up and then just I mean
I'm you know I'm not good with names I
know but I feel like you're today is
Ethan what what time do you go to bed
extra
time to go to bed I declined to stay
yeah you so casually were like no I got
plenty of sleep I don't know
did you I don't know I don't know
anymore I don't know
like sometimes I sleep for like four
hours and I feel fine and some days I
sleep for like six or seven hours and I
I just can't keep track of it all so you
don't have like a schedule like okay
this is when I'm going to bed no
schedule no schedule
absolutely no schedule so can we get
some breaking news
um music going actually because this is
a break there's no Mr Beast festivals
here whoa there are no Mr Beast
festivals I cannot believe this this is
a travesty
wow
now what is going on where did they all
go Facebook we looked everywhere we
looked behind here in front of her all
over the place and there were no Mr B's
feastfuls that's an outrageous stuff wow
that is that is just [__] up like
we're we looked underneath we looked for
any anywhere else and there are just
none here
no Mr B's festivals I cannot believe it
this is this is outrageous it's
outrageous so can we ask I guess we
should ask an employee if they have
anything yeah because they need to get
them out it's like if you guys got them
in back you need to get it on the floor
right now that's right
you know how there's always a few
products on the on the side oh okay and
yeah we don't see anything here at all
wow and there's no there's not at the
front I I noticed in some of the other
pictures
let's take a look do you think one of
the running villains got there first and
maybe they run hit them no no no do you
think someone confiscated it what is
that that's just sugar or something
ask him
Nathan do you know if there's any uh
chocolate bars
online only he says online
he that's not true we were just at a
wall exactly
I think he's a I think he's an enemy of
the stage yeah yeah
the next one
well I like Rolos maybe fix up the Rolos
[Laughter]
what are you afraid of Ian I just love
Eddie's just there fixing up the candy
house and do we see any Hershey's Eddie
yeah I see a bunch of Hershey's right
yeah you know what to do you know what
to do to those
atta boy
sometimes I go shopping and I'm looking
for an item and they just put it
somewhere else like they're trying to
highlight it but then it's somewhere and
you can't find it right register maybe
yeah register is it maybe at the front
they have a display or something yeah we
can go check and see if maybe the
display has them at the front
yeah let's go check it out I think I
mean I find it hard to believe that they
don't have Beasts bars I know everything
they always say that when it's oh it's
only online whenever they don't have it
in stock oh can you do me a favor Eddie
or a cam yeah those those uh nerds
can you buy a couple of those do you
have a do you have a company card cam he
doesn't no but I'll hit you back I'll
hit you back okay hit me back yeah
everybody
that's it which one that's good that's
good just yeah those can you actually
have them you guys want something yeah
can you pan to the right a little bit
just a couple products to the right yeah
the sour patches now recently Sour Patch
started releasing a Blue Sour Patch only
do they have any blue just Blues yeah no
it doesn't look like it oops it's the
variety pack
is that just watermelon
yeah they have sour
ly Rose hey Eddie you want something you
want you you see us something on the
Shelf you like oh yeah I'm good thank
you though Ethan you sure he's on his
head Journey okay maybe if those are if
those are watermelon only Sour Patch
Kids grab me one of those do you want to
grab the watermelon ones right there
yeah
um thank you so much yeah that's perfect
yeah you know I don't even like nerds
but I hit those I think Lena had them or
something and I was like what the [__]
these are slap huh of course they do
dudes no but it's like the texture of
chewy and crunchy I've been ordering
them to Sweden so let's let's go oh wow
let's try to find another employee to
ask because that guy didn't seem to okay
and a lot of people were saying check by
the registers and I think that's my
registers they have candy bars yeah the
registers in the front because I think
maybe I'm afraid that what if they get
kicked out before they get our Sour
Patch Kids oh yeah oh that's a I'm
willing to risk that can we maybe maybe
Eddie should put the shirt on just for a
minute so no no no no no no no no no no
don't Ethan it's gonna be so
disappointed this is a long line
don't interfere Dan
this is Art we can get nerds anymore
we'll check the checks we're looking for
the bars right now how's the Lego
section there true not everyone has the
watermelon okay guys guys he's not your
He's Not Your Shopper we're not doing it
what if they have the Indiana Jones
Legos there oh dude those are unreleased
uh Walmart exclusive but they put them
in any Beast bars
here what about there's got to be
there's got to be a display in the
entrance I just find it hard to believe
there's no Beast bars yeah I thought it
was you it was in all Walmarts
ask him where they are
where are they
part of the distribution
uh Jeff says he can do a call so I'll
call him after this
by the entrance can you just ask uh ask
one more employee and then we'll we'll
call it a day because I just we went all
the way out there okay let's find an
employee Eddie yeah
I mean we went all the way out there
like did we get Jeff on the same Zoom
call with Eddie right now just send him
the link I'm just gonna call him he's at
the airport he said you could try to
send him a link I guess I don't know you
have his contact info that's not let's
find him please
we're not that tight yes so we are in
the Walmart this one doesn't appear to
have Beast bars which is a travesty to
be honest I'm not comfortable with that
and we are going to management to act
you know what
what we had something of his I'm not
sure whether we have the bar
down that way
okay yep thank you thank you
[Music]
man she doesn't say [__] he has us on
speakerphone no I know
I guess I can't open it it's just
amazing she doesn't care at all that
you're sure
in Walmart it would be like really I
don't know you would really take note of
it
Mr Beast cookies
okay that's a good call it's Walmart
only you know if yeah no I'm saying I
wouldn't be as shocked at Walmart at
Target I'd be shocked yeah yeah
I thought for sure they're gonna kick
you out man
wow
have you ever had Mr Fish These Bars
here
what's your favorite stuff
that's my first time here so
all right well Eddie I don't want to
waste your time do you want to shoot one
of your videos you can put those down we
could always go to another yeah you
could put those down Eddie you don't you
don't got to do that thank you and Eddie
I don't want you to waste your time
there do you want to shoot some of your
videos Tick Tock videos sure yeah go
ahead yeah let's do it we'll watch
you would just say hey Eddie what are
you doing in the Walmart with your shirt
off I mean I wish I could I got anything
oh okay there you go nice try it so that
was a polite decline oh thank you shut
down I think we find anyone else sure oh
here's the man would you do this video
with me I brought some money you need to
say hey Eddie what are you doing in the
Walmart with your shirt out put your
shirt back on it okay ready again
put your shirt back on
that looks really good could you still
need yeah
if I can be in a Walmart
with my shirt because I'm Eddie I can do
that okay
yes I can be in a Walmart
it will not move this is the best
content oh there we go
okay
yes I can be in a Walmart with my shirt
up because I'm nitty I can be to Walmart
with my shirt off because I'm ready I'm
ready
around on me
so is that a typical encounter for you
Eddie yeah that's a typical encounter
sometimes they'll do it you know I
appreciate you get them you get them
real fast almost before they can even
think about what they're doing that's
what I was saying earliest running Gun
Man
let's get some more right
this process is just fascinating to me I
love watching it Eddie I could watch you
all the way just real let me just remind
you are we going to lose Jeff is he
getting on a plane to be fair I don't
think anything's gonna top this
I can't interrupt this this is this is
important okay Ethan sorry Jeff I'll
call you when you land
this man's walking around shirtless in
Walmart
ah so we're on the prowl for
another collaborator
he's not so I noticed he's not he passed
by them why didn't you ask them Eddie
yeah
Eddie what are you looking for like what
kind of person are you looking for
well anybody that's kind of recently
when he was doing this video with
Australia
he doesn't want he don't want anything
to do with that and that's fair that's
fair
so Eddie I noticed you congratulations
congrats wait what do you say okay he
just took off 50 pounds oh oh that's
nice oh that's so nice sharing their War
Stories
oh here's our lady that might do it
right he's going to see me but I noticed
Eddie I noticed you walked past a few
people what about them made you think
they're not going to be good to ask
oh yeah yeah
exterior of like they're in a hurry or
they're grumpy right okay okay okay
hey Eddie what are you doing in the
Walmart with your shirt off put your
shirt back on Jeff
in the one month
birthday thank you so much thank you
and then just push the red button when
I'm ready ready
that's how we do it what a legend
it was perfect it was perfect keep going
man
maybe I think the ultimate would be if
you can get an employee to do it Eddie
right I mean that would be yeah that
would be an All-Star
the Walmart employees have enough to
worry about ask him ask him
oh dude
everyone's like I don't get paid enough
videos exactly
it's amazing
very much so that's how we do it
that's when Slim Pickens
there's a lady there that might do it
oh boy this is incredible to see the
behind the scenes of these videos I mean
it's so so powerful yeah I'm on cloud
nine right now this is awesome you get
away with it how are you feeling cam are
you feeling like kind of like I don't
know embarrassed I mean that's what I
might feel if I was there uh I'm hiding
behind the camera that's for sure
oh goodness okay would you help me out
I'm doing this video
no not the kid no not the kid
don't show the kid don't show the kid
yeah I don't want anything to do with
that that's perfect
yeah good old Quaker Oats
we love me some Quaker Oats boy
I can do it Eddie I can get you
yeah
well okay just press that red button
yes I'm here one sec one second I'm here
in the Walmart with my shirt off and my
name is Eddie and I've lost weight so I
look great so I can only be sure losing
Walmart because I'm Eddie
all right thank you so much fantastic so
how many is that in the hole that's like
three of them eh yeah yeah I got three
of them so far I think uh but I think
we're good
but what do you think should we get one
more Ethan to me to me you would have a
viral video if you could get an employee
no an employee would get fired for doing
that don't in person yeah 100 like no
questions asked they instantly got fired
they're done so don't do it yeah no
employees
100.
100 he said well then say no oh okay
okay I don't want anyone get in trouble
sometimes
[Music]
I mean I could watch this for
another 30 minutes for sure
and is then would you like to be in the
video with us
thank you my goodness
oh there is one right there maybe
would you like to do it would you help
us out
you just say hey what are you doing
okay ready to say hey I lost weight
recently so I like to do a video you
know for my picture already yeah hey
Eddie what are you doing in the Walmart
with your shirt off put your shirt back
on
nice try I appreciate the candles
no way
uh Jeff's in the lobby should I just
drop him in yeah just bring them in
maybe you can mute Eddie's yeah I'll
feed and then we'll just talk to Jeffrey
hey Eddie what are you doing okay that's
cool well we could just we could just
let Eddie go no no no no no no no no no
mute Eddie that's reaction I want to see
both okay let me see if I can do that
hold on perfect that one word and said
now would you just take me real quick
put the red button
okay a muted cam okay yeah so Jeff's
coming in cam you can just tell Eddie
that we're on we're I don't want him to
think you know
just tell them we're taking another call
real fast but but we're still he's still
alive literally on the plane oh [__]
you're on the plane
hey guys where are you going
um can you hear me yeah I can hear you
where you guys headed we're heading back
to LA baby thanks for having me on the
show big fan
yeah of course anytime friend of the
show always welcome
look at this hi Tana we love you
there's tons of celebs over here this
guy's on a Netflix show he's been doing
a podcast right now
Jeff what's what's going on where are
you where are you coming from I went to
a wedding in Miami okay you might
actually know the girl she paved away
from women's comedy on the internet Lily
Pons oh you were there shortly yeah yeah
how was the wedding man
it was a big clout Fest it was like uh
I mean I don't even I don't even know
how to explain it I I believe it was a
it was a beautiful ceremony you know a
lot of big money
star-studded lineup that's nice how was
the meal was the food good
food was good yeah I had a steak town
and didn't want to eat her steak I had
her two steaks nice open bar
yeah but you know me I no but you don't
care but it was a nice ceremony I was
having some sodas you know getting a
little crazy a little couple couple
Pepsi Maxes hey oh yeah what did you get
her I'm curious
what gifts yeah
uh just our presence was the present
because she's filthy rich
that's awesome no problem no no I mean
look I I was looking for like the thing
you know they send out the thing like
where you could buy stuff or whatever
yeah the registry registry yeah yeah and
she said no there was none
okay
is it bad am I gonna take off the plane
yeah I told him down I gotta turn it
down okay I'll just I'll cut to the
chase here I wanted to ask you about
Chet Hanks apparently we were just
watching Chet Hank's video and someone
said you did a episode with him that you
refused to air is that true
yeah yeah
[__] man he promised he made me promise
that I would never talk about this
because it went horrible and it's not a
good look on on our production I hired
some new actors at that time when the
barbershop
I'm sure familiar with it you did the
show obviously thanks for doing that of
course anytime
um it used to be a lot more wild and we
had a Tom Hanks impersonator come in and
freestyle rap about his relationship
with his father and it just went South
it was not a good time that sounds like
it would have been really funny he
wasn't receptive to it
is not not the best time to do it and
the the guys that I was working with the
actors were so in character that they
did not stop that's awesome dude that
sounds
I know I know I mean look that's why you
were such a great guest because you
don't give a [__] you let us give you
double Mohawks and then you got canceled
the next week you know yeah I got
canceled with that
I love that it's in all the pictures it
is Philly DeFranco used in the thumbnail
my hair is growing back I'm almost due
for another cup
let's do it maybe next time you can give
me like a nice one for real that people
be happy about that
yeah I would like that too because
people think I just [__] around and you
know attack people with with uh
freestyle rappers impersonators of the
father and just give [__] haircuts but
so about the Chet Hanks episode uh do
you so like after you guys rap do you
how did you all just come to this
agreement that I should never see the
light of day
oh he was mad he was mad and
understandably like the kid went way too
far that I was working with who's this
guy over here with this uh pasties on
his nipples that's shirtless Eddie bro
he's Tick-Tock famous he's our boy he's
at Walmart right now shooting videos
with people
oh yeah
okay I I haven't been watching the show
it's been dizzy in Miami I'll get caught
up when I get no it's okay just when
you're on Tick Tock look up shirtless
Eddie
okay I'll check him out
yeah is that it anything else no I just
I just wanted to yeah but I just wanted
to hear from you say hi you know Friends
of the show as well I just want to see
you it's nice to see your face
I appreciate it same let me see a b
how's he doing hey buddy guys training I
was training it's going good man thanks
for asking it's going good nice I saw
that pic you and Freddie Roach oh yes
you're gonna kill this guy you're gonna
kill him thank you buddy I gotta stop
see I gotta stop yelling things like
that yeah yeah keep that down
you're gonna kill him
okay so well I I want to ask you more
about the chat thing it's so interesting
to me so he was angry and like were you
gonna post it did something happen
afterwards where he where he convinced
you not to post it did you want to post
it and he didn't
no I I knew that it worked too far and
it was like just really disrespectful
and and you know his dad's in Illuminati
so I don't want to you know have my
career in Hollywood ruined over one
episode it was just a barbershop episode
you know we we only got about five nice
to meet you Jeff I'm heading back to the
studio now but it's a lovely time here
and we really enjoyed meeting you thank
you Jeff and nice to see you guys we're
heading back to the studio now oh thank
God you should be a you should be a host
or like Survivor or something like one
of those Network reality shows yeah
great voice for that man thank you so
much I really appreciate that Anytime
Anyplace I'll be there
all right all right hell yeah
yeah so shirtless Eddie are you guys
coming back to the studio now yeah we're
gonna head back to the studio now
all right you guys did awesome thank you
guys so much fantastic well done well
done uh shirtless Jeff's Chef shirtless
Eddie went to Walmart to protect the Mr
Beast chocolate displays and to clean
them up
are they getting ransacked by yeah they
well this yeah Raiders haters Mr B
uh
you guys can hold that shot Eddie
I like that shot I mean you guys are
just not going anywhere are you
okay we can move around
it's up to you man he's perfect yeah no
you're perfect the way you are
uh do you want to run do you want to run
again sure oh yeah I like that and then
so so Jeff um
would you be open to having a private
screening with us
oh I gotta see if we even have that
footage so I don't think we do
um private screen it was like five
minutes so he got in he was like what
the [__]
did he not know what he was like getting
himself into I feel like it's a zany
show no it's you'd be surprised you know
a lot of people don't really watch the
show they'll just come on and then you
know next thing you know your dad's
coming out and missing you about your
relationship with your brother and how
yeah your brother was his favorite child
and oh yeah it was deep it hit him too
hard it hit him too hard
yeah I don't know what the [__] we were
doing you know it's a haircut show
it's the concept is funny as hell
but I think he uh he wasn't such a baby
he blocked me on Instagram
uh for for making fun of his Jamaican
accent he threatened me he actually
threatened to beat me
oh yeah over that I feel like everybody
yeah
no he threatened me
I mean that's way way less harsh than
what we did you know yeah I didn't I
think that's pretty light
all right yeah I just wanted to hear
about that that's so interesting I'd
love to uh
yeah if if you have it we can watch it
privately that'd be fun but I get it if
you don't whatever you know whatever you
got yeah I'm sorry I'm just doing a
podcast right now it's live
did he say
something about crashing did he say that
he said like if I turn airplane mode off
is the plane Really Gonna crash yeah
that's what I thought he said as an Arab
that really I was scared for him you
could never say that
that's a great reference uh Zach yeah
that was pretty special moment the two
public disruptions happening live
in two separate locations powerful Eddie
they're never kicking you out of there
man this is kind of like the uh he found
Paradise yeah he's fine yeah can you
unlock the plane but he's fine
that sucks that Chet's such a baby
that sounds like it would have been
funny
yeah
maybe maybe that should have been in the
back half maybe that was right don't
open with that yeah that's that's coming
on pretty strong right now is that yeah
let's just get let's just go back Eddie
Eddie this is like the promised land
they're not kicking you out for anything
no they don't care
is this the longest you've gone into
Walmart before being asked to leave
Walmart
foreign
is this the longest you've been in a
Walmart shirtless yes it is it really is
Cam uh and Cam and I have been in here
shirtless and uh it is Ethan it's the
longest I've ever been in Ethan in a
Walmart with my shirt off for this long
even mate they just don't care I don't
think they'll kick you out for anything
that's pretty incredible they haven't
even been fed and there have been people
here watching us and they don't say
anything and it's been great how does
that feel to be accepted for who you are
in a Walmart
I feel so free and so like I'm uh
I feel great like I'm one of these lost
people here they're doing it's accepting
yeah that's awesome that's beautiful so
you guys headed out now cam
uh I hope so
yeah we should release them we've been
going for uh three and a half hours so
uh we should probably ready you are the
man thank you so much you we had such a
fun episode today thanks to you
I told everyone to follow you on Tick
Tock okay we're gonna get you that
hundred thousand
yeah we're gonna get you there we're
gonna get you there for sure thank you
so and thank you Cam
yeah thank you and um yeah thanks again
thank you guys good job thank you all
such a fun such a great segment thank
you guys all right don't forget the
studio all right God bless God bless Kim
have a good night
no he goes have a good night
wow have a good night
that was special special times man
we could review the tick tock song a
Nook has responded to comments on Tick
Tock about the podcast yeah we saw that
Meredith said thank you so much he has
not responded to DMS as of yet so
well maybe he looked into it was like
[__] that I don't want anything to do
you should check his insta DMS from the
podcast Instagram he has one from from
us and one individually from me too can
you see if it's red
I can look
I wonder if he left this on red
he hadn't read mine
if he doesn't respond we should just
have one of those edits
what eBay I said if he doesn't respond
we should just send him one of those
edits of him in the spacesuit how can we
get him to see it though I think he
would love it if he saw it you know can
we just
uh can we just post it on Tick Tock and
tag him I would love to try that let's
try that I'm like Stitch him or
something can you do that love he might
see it yeah Stitch you do it you can
stitch him you tag him oh he uh oh ela's
watching she said what a fun Show
podcast avant-garde thank you thank you
that's what we love here we pushed the
envelope we re-imagine nobody's walk
nobody's doing what we're doing nobody
and nobody is sticking up for Mr Beast
not even close not even close
yeah I hope that we've proven our
although we really
I think we tapped into something
interesting that Beast has to get on top
of is that some of these Walmarts are
not putting his [__] out on display
right yeah that doesn't seem right
subterfuge it doesn't it doesn't I'm
just saying it seems like subterfuge to
me
it seems like that to me too yeah
oh did I retweet for my main account
hold on let me do that
the uh
the Mr Beast one oh that's this is so
good
before and after
Alexa donate five dollars said yes
please leave so that I can get started
my grocery run I've been in the Burger
Burbank parking lot for a hundred years
at this point scared to run into you uh
they are not at the Burbank location I
will I will tell you that you are good
to go
and get that shopping done
this is so awesome I'm just looking at
our the podcast tweets about it it's
just the best
it is just the best
and
I gotta say
quite a show we have here absolutely and
I'm very very excited about the lore
stuff we're doing I think it will really
help
people who want to get their friends
fans whoever in on the show we're gonna
build out a really special lore video
and it'll be fun for
old fans and new fans alike to walk down
that memory lane I think it'll be a lot
of fun
have a good night have a good night cap
nice gift at five thank you so much
well I guess we've been going for a
while now
yep yeah we'll probably wrap it up we'll
wrap it up yeah and thank you guys for
watching as usual we'll be back tomorrow
for members I'll be live as usual
I'll see you next Tuesday
and uh pretty and and leftovers is back
genius congrats on 30 months that's
awesome thank you so much God Diane
man and it's gonna be
[Music]
should see if we can
do a super size leftovers or something
this week because
the two weeks that he was gone were like
the busiest weeks in a long time and
conservative nonsense so maybe a lot of
material we should try to just do like a
lightning Focus I know that won't ever
happen though but we could try I like
the idea I'm sure you guys are going to
want to talk about his uh Japan trip and
everything too so you know we'll do what
we can but
all right guys thanks everyone for being
here we will be back as usual on
Wednesday and for members I'll see you
all tomorrow thank you so much so just
get up there and protect that feastable
display
put your life on it it's all that
matters thank you also too peanut butter
FICO well that's so nice 10 gifted subs
thank you so much
saluting and signing out I pledge my
life to you Mr Beast
have a good night
thank you
[Music]
foreign